Zwei Sprechstunden. Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Der Sendung, wo in regelmäßigen Abständen der Chaos Computer Club oder nähere Expertinnen und Experten aus dem Umfeld, der das Studio enttarnt, um Dinge zu erklären, die irgendwie mit diesem seltsamen Internet zu tun haben oder neuartigen Rotfunk- umfangsgeräten oder irgendwas anderes digitales. Und heute wird es politisch. Heute wollen wir mal angucken, wie das aussieht mit der nächsten Bundestagswahl. Die ist ja bald, also im Herbst. Und da gibt es ja viele Wahlversprechen und viele Themen. Und da wollen wir uns hier in einem Chaosradio natürlich eher den digitalen widmen. Aber es ist ja sehr einfach, immer auf Wahlversprechen zu gucken und dann zu überlegen, ja gefällt mir das oder nicht. Wir wollen heute auch das machen. Aber viel sinnvoll ist ja vielleicht mal zurückzugucken und zu gucken, was haben denn die, die da waren, an der Macht, in der Regierung oder vielleicht auch einfach im Parlament gesessen, in den letzten Jahren so getrieben, in den letzten vier Jahren. Das wollen wir heute mal hier genauer uns angucken und anhören. Und dazu grüße ich recht herzlich Katharina Nocun. Hallo, guten Abend. Christian Dschefal. Hallo.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Und Anna Wiesely. Hallo, guten Abend. So, wir machen heute eine Zeitreise zurück ins Jahr 2013. Das Jahr 2013, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, was war das? Also musikalisch war Avicii die Hochzeit. Merkle-Mohr war gerade ganz berühmt und Merkel hat, also die sagt ja sozusagen, in meiner Erinnerung, ganz wenige Sachen, die einem im Gedächtnis bleiben wirklich. Aber in dem Jahr ist ein Satz gefallen, der sie wohl für immer begleiten wird.
Das Internet ist für uns alle Neuland.
Und das hat sie gesagt kurz nachdem Snowden an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen ist, mit den ganzen Leagues. Die Snowden Leagues haben auch in diesem Jahr ihren Anfang genommen. Das war alles im Sommer. Und man fragt sich also, hm, also das Internet, also Neuland 2013. Na gut. Und dann ist ja vielleicht die Frage, ja, an diesen Satz kann man sich erinnern. Aber in welchem Zusammenhang ist der eigentlich gefallen? Der ist im Zusammenhang gefallen, dass Barack Obama da war und klingt ein bisschen länger so.
Das Internet ist für uns alle Neuland. Und es ermöglicht auch Feinden und Gegnern unserer demokratischen Grundordnung natürlich mit völlig neuen Möglichkeiten und völlig neuen Herangehensweisen unsere Art zu leben, in Gefahr zu bringen.
Also das Internet ist etwas Neues und wir müssen davor Angst haben wegen der Feinde. Das war so der Stand 2013. Und wie es von dort bis heute gegangen ist, das wollen wir uns heute mal genauer sprechen. Und jetzt würde ich von euch, liebe Studio Gäste, gerne mal wissen, was ihr für eine Entwicklung sozusagen durchgemacht habt in den letzten vier Jahren. Katharina, du warst damals Geschäftsführerin der Piraten. Was ist seitdem passiert? Oder bist du das immer noch?
Nein, also ich wurde zur politischen Geschäftsführerin der Piratenpartei nachgewählt. Also ich war die Nachfolgerin von Johannes Ponada mit einem recht sozialistischen Wahlergebnis auch angetreten. Und für mich war der Wahlabend tatsächlich ziemlich deprimierend, weil wir krachend natürlich die 5%-Hürde als Piraten nicht gepackt haben. Ich wusste das auch ein bisschen vorher. Man kriegt ja als Partei so Exit-Polls, sag ich mal, bevor die offiziellen Zahlen rausgehen. Das heißt, man konnte sich auch ein bisschen vorbereiten. Man hat auch ein bisschen damit gerechnet, aber es war halt trotzdem knüppelhart. Und ich habe mich danach entschieden, einen Monat später war auch so meine normale Wahlperiode vorbei, dann nicht wieder anzutreten. Und ja, habe danach in den Jahren ziemlich viel für NGOs gearbeitet und mich viel eher in der digitalen Bürgerrechtsbewegung umgetrieben und bin auch im Herbst letzten Jahres dann aus der Partei ausgetreten.
Bist aber sozusagen mit dem Thema, also nicht nur digital Bürgerrechte durchsetzen, sondern auch, du beschätzt dich auch noch mit dem Digitalen.
Ja klar, also es war ja auch schon vor den Piraten in der Falle. Also ich bin quasi zur Politik gekommen, durch den Arbeitskreis gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil ich damals dachte, bei vielen Gesetzen gibt es ja irgendjemanden, der kümmert sich drum, aber bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung hatte ich das Gefühl, viele Leute, gerade der Bundestag, checkt eigentlich nicht, was für ein krasses Überwachungsgesetz das ist. Ja, und hab dann auch zwischenzeitlich mal für die Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband gearbeitet in der Abteilung, die berühmt berüchtigt ist für ihre Abmahnung gegen Facebook, Google und Apple und Co.
Okay, herzlich willkommen. Christian Giefal, du warst damals Doktorand.
Genau, ich hab damals zu einem nicht digitalen Thema an der Humboldt-Universität promoviert und damals aber schon sozusagen meine Leidenschaft für digitale Themen entdeckt und hab deswegen in dem Rechtsreferendariat, was jeder Jurist ja machen muss, versucht, besonders viele Stationen in dem Bereich zu machen. Ich war zum Beispiel beim Datenschutz bei Siemens oder bei einer IT-Rechtskanzlei und hab dann im Anschluss daran versucht, in der Wissenschaft weiterzumachen. Bin jetzt am Humboldt-Institut für Internet und Gesellschaft in Berlin gelandet.
Herzlich willkommen. Du wirst uns vor allen Dingen dabei helfen, dass wir dann in die Zukunft auch blicken können. Anna Bieseli, du warst damals Praktikantin bei einem kleinen Blog, Netzpolitik hieß das. Das ist immer noch, also nicht, dass du Praktikerin bist, aber bei dem Blog bist du immer noch, oder?
Genau, ich war damals, sag ich mal, frisch mit dem Informatikstudium fertig und wollte eigentlich nur mal ein Praktikum machen und bin so ein bisschen dahingeblieben, was auch im Endeffekt ganz gut war, weil es gab ja genug zu tun und hab quasi ab, ich glaube, Oktober 2013, als es so mit der neuen Regierung mehr oder weniger losging, dann eben auch die Netzpolitik relativ doll verfolgt.
Dann auch dir herzlich willkommen. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, also bevor wir uns tatsächlich ins Jahr 2013 nach der Wahl begeben, die ja nach diesem nekretigen Satz war, wollte ich tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, einmal noch.
Das Internet ist für uns alle Neuland.
Und ihr habt mir auf der Herfahrt, die wird zusammen unternommen, ja schon erzählt, eigentlich stimmt das nicht. Eigentlich stimmt das nicht, was man der Politik immer unterstellt auch und was sozusagen hier auch clever benutzt wurde, dass man sagt, das Internet ist was ganz Neues, das gibt's schon länger. Seit wann, seit wann weiß denn die Bundesregierung eigentlich, dass da draußen ein Internet ist?
Ja, seit sie es spätestens seit sie gelernt hat, wie man es überwacht. Aber es war natürlich, sag ich mal, aus Campaignersicht ein eiskalter, geschickter Spin.
Dieser Satz meinst du jetzt?
Der Satz war kein Zufall, der Satz war vorgegeben und der war auch genauso geplant. Und es war auch, denke ich, schon gedacht, dass der genauso einschlägt. Und das hat Folgendes bewirkt, sag ich mal, bei vielen älteren Unionswählern, dass sie gesagt haben, so fühle ich mich ja auch vielleicht. Und die Leute, die gesagt haben, na ja, wir unterstellen da jetzt mal eine böse Absicht, wurden durch diesen Spin so ein bisschen als die Besserwisser dargestellt. Und nachher politisch betrachtet war das ein geschickter Mover, aber es war natürlich eine eiskalte Lüge. Man hat in der Zwischenzeit diverse Male über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung diskutiert, diverse Überwachungsgesetze online wie offline durchgebracht. Also es ist was Neues, es ist ja vollkommener Bullshit gewesen.
Und ich habe auch noch mal so ein bisschen überlegt, also die Zeit, wo Netzpolitik auch gegründet wurde, das war ja so 2004 rum. Und da war die Debatte um die ganzen Softwarepatente und um den ganzen Einsatz von Open-Source-Software schon ziemlich groß. Das heißt irgendwie, damals gab es das halt auch schon. Und danach hatte man, ich glaube so 2008, 2009, diese ganze Kinderpornodebatte, die riesig aufgekocht ist. Das heißt irgendwie so große Themen. Und nicht nur so dieses Internet ist halt da und wir ignorieren. Das gab es halt schon ziemlich häufig.
Hast du auch noch Erkenntnisse aus der Frühzeit des politischen, digitalen?
Ja, also die digitale Verwaltung hat ja schon wesentlich früher angefangen. In Deutschland ist das ein großes Problem. Aber in einzelnen Bundesländern hat man früher auch schon angefangen, Portale aufzubauen und sich damit beschäftigt. Auch das Postministerium hat sozusagen in der Deregulierung das damalige sich intensiv damit beschäftigt. Deswegen ist der Begriff sich ja bewusst gewählt, aber nicht ganz akkurat.
Verstehe. Also die wussten schon, dass es da Internet gibt. Wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, was so passiert ist in der letzten Legislaturperiode. Wir haben hier freundlicherweise in der Vorbereitung eine ganze Timeline bekommen. Das erste Gesetz, was man hat, was überhaupt grob in die Richtung geht, ist Ende 2014. 2013 war Bundestagswahl. Da muss jetzt mal die erfahrenen politischen Beobachter fragen, ist das normal, dass ein Jahr lang nichts passiert oder ist dann in dem Jahr lang ganz viel anderes passiert? Und digital ist es einfach zu sagen, so weit nach hinten priorisiert worden. Ja, das ist noch Neuland, da kümmern wir uns darum, wenn der wichtige Kram erledigt ist. Oder warum ist das so?
Na ja, ich glaube, es gibt so zwei Begründungen. Weil die eine Begründung, die ganz trivial ist und für alle möglichen Bereiche zutrifft, ist, dass die meisten Gesetze so kurz vor Ende der Legislatur gemacht werden. Das heißt, da fällt einem ein Mensch, da stand in diesem Koalitionsvertrag hier irgendwas drin, was müssen wir noch machen? Und dann kommt plötzlich so Panikgesetzgebung. Und das andere Ding, man hatte im ersten Jahr zwar nicht so wirklich Gesetze, die man gemacht hat, aber man hatte mit anderen Sachen zu tun. Das heißt, man hat ja 2014, so März, April, diesen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss eingesetzt. Das war ja auch eine Nummer, mit der man relativ gut beschäftigt war. Und dann hat man diese ganze Debatte gehabt, um diesen ominösen Bundestagsausschuss für die digitale Agenda. Das heißt, da hat man sich erst mal überlegt, was für eine Bedeutung geben wir dem Thema? Wird das jetzt ein eigenes Ministerium? Oder machen wir diesen Ausschuss? Wie machen wir diesen Ausschuss? Was macht dieser Ausschuss überhaupt? Und wie teilen wir so ein bisschen das Gehege auf? Das heißt, dann kommt dann der Internetminister I und der Internetminister II. Und wie kriegen die ihre Aufgaben verteilt?
Ja, man darf ja nicht vergessen, dass Snowden wirklich 2013 das Thema aller Schlagzeilen, also jeder zweiten Schlagzeile war. Und zwar auch nach der Wahl. Also ich kann mich erinnern, ich hab in der Zeit, ich glaube, allein dreimal vor dem Bundestag eine Demonstration angemeldet und durchgeführt für Asyl für Edwards-Norden. Und das hatte eine riesige Unterstützung. Weit abseits der üblichen Nordkreise. Da ist halt Omi und Oppy angekommen und hat noch die Enkel mitgeschleppt, weil sie gesagt haben, das geht nicht, dass dieser junge, gute Mann jetzt hier schutzlos ausgeliefert ist quasi. Ich denke, das war auch so teilweise eine Art politische Vorsicht, die da weiten gelassen wurde, die auch nicht umberechtigt war. Weil direkt in der Zeit ein Überwachungsgesetz zu knüppeln, wo es noch ganz frisch war, wär heikel gewesen.
Dann ist es aber sozusagen, wie gesagt, das ist der erste Termin, in dem wir drin stehen, haben wir Ende 2014 zum Gesetz zur Änderung des Anti-Terror-Dateigesetzes und anderer Gesetze gekommen. Als Nichtjurist rolle ich die Augen und frage mich, was ist da passiert? Könnt ihr das vielleicht noch mal genauer erläutern? Anti-Terror-Dateigesetz?
Grundlegend, was man so im einen Satz sagen kann, ist, dass diese Anti-Terror-Dateien von einer reinen Datenbestandsdatei zu einer Analysedatei geworden sind. Da hat man quasi gesagt, ihr dürft die Daten nicht nur sammeln, sondern ihr dürft jetzt auch automatisiert irgendwelche Sachen rüberlaufen lassen, um Erkenntnisse zu bekommen. Da hat ein Gericht gesagt, das geht so nicht, dann braucht ihr ein neues Gesetz, da braucht ihr eine Grundlage für, was ihr gerade macht. Dann hat man eben gesagt, wenn da jetzt zum Beispiel Aufnahmen aus Telefonüberwachung drin sind, dann muss man da ja irgendwas mit tun, weil die kann sich ja nicht jedes Mal jemand anhören. Dann geben wir denen die Befugnisse, dass sie da automatisiert Sachen rüberlaufen lassen können und Daten verknüpfen können und dann eben ihre mutmaßlich Verdächtigen finden können. Das heißt, da hat man einfach das Recht erweitert, mit dieser Datei zu arbeiten.
War das damals ein großer Aufreger oder ist das einfach so über die Bühne gegangen?
Ich kann mich nicht mehr so richtig daran erinnern, was vielleicht darauf hindeutet, dass es kein großer Aufreger war. Das heißt, ich glaube, so eine richtig große Aufmerksamkeit dafür gab es nicht. Irgendwie die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hat dann irgendwann gesagt, das geht irgendwie so nicht, aber da kam dann auch nichts mehr und danach hat sich auch nicht mehr wirklich jemand daran erinnert, weil da kamen ja noch ein paar schlimmere Sachen, dann kann man das einfach vergessen.
Ist das eigentlich sozusagen so auch als Masche, in den letzten Jahren dann zu beobachten? Es werden Gesetze verabschiedet und dann passieren aber andere Dinge, die das vergessen lassen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine absichtliche Masche ist. Ich glaube, das ist einfach so die natürliche Entwicklung der Dinge unter einer großen Koalition.
Na ja, aber was auf jeden Fall eine Masche ist, was man nochmal festhalten kann, sind, man sollte immer sehr vorsichtig sein, was im Bundestag passiert, wenn Fußball gespielt wird. Also zur WM und EM, das ist immer der beliebteste Zeitpunkt, um dann Dinge durchzubringen.
So, dann haben wir schon nächstes Jahr, 2015, Gesetz zur Einführung einer Infrastrukturabgabe für die Benutzung von Bundesfernstraßen. Wieso, liebe digitalen Natives, die hier im Studio sitzen, warum sind Bundesfernstraßen jetzt Teil des Chaosradios? Was ist da passiert?
Na, man könnte doch einfach sagen, Kennzeichenscanner.
Es ist ja schon lange, dass wir diese Maut-Dinger haben, wo Kameras Kennzeichenscannen und die für LKWs die Maut abrechnen. Und das ist dann da auch wieder erweitert worden?
Na ja, man hat ja gesagt, wir benutzen die erstmal nur, um wirklich diese Abrechnungsgeschichten zu machen. Und dann hat man auch gesagt, auf jeden Fall benutzen wir die nicht, um irgendwelche Strafverfolgung zu machen. Und gerade so dieses Kfz-Kennzeichenscanner zur Strafverfolgung oder so zum Nachverfolgung von Leuten, das ist ja mehr in Landespolizeigesetzen geregelt. Das heißt, das betrifft das noch gar nicht so wirklich. Aber allein dadurch, dass man eine Infrastruktur schafft, um diese ganzen Kennzeichen zu scannen, war damit eben die Befürchtung da, dass man die Daten dann später vielleicht dann doch, obwohl man gesagt hat, das werden wir auf keinen Fall tun, zu anderen Zwecken verwendet.
Das ist ja eine Befürchtung, die immer gerade, was die Überwachungsgesetze angeht, dann kommt. Hat sich das dann noch so bewahrheitet? Ich hab irgendwas im Kopf, dass es tatsächlich dann irgendwie so war, dass man Mautdaten mittlerweile viel mehr benutzen kann, als nur die Abrechnung.
Naja, es gab ja diesen Fall mit dem, sag ich mal, Autobahnmörder, der dann quasi auf Leute geschossen hat. Ich weiß nicht mehr, ob der genau welche umgebracht hat, aber ich weiß, dass in der Debatte eben dieses konkrete Beispiel dann immer gebracht wurde und tatsächlich wurde dieser jemand dann auch über eine Datenerfassung gefasst, was natürlich extrem schwierig macht, dagegen zu argumentieren, weil bei den meisten Politikern, sag ich mal, eher dieses praktische Ding im Vordergrund steht. Naja, aber wir haben ihnen gefasst, dass man dann halt Millionen einfach unschuldige Menschen rastert, das gerät dann schnell in den Hintergrund.
Wir werden auch ganz viel über digitale Überwachung auch noch sprechen, aber wie ist denn das generell, diese Kameras im öffentlichen Raum, also da ist ja die Mautkameras sozusagen fast noch was abstraktes, weil da geht es halt nur um Kennzeichnissen und sowas, aber die, also gerade wenn man sich hier in Berlin umguckt, in den öffentlichen Nahverkehrsmitteln, zum Beispiel da sind ja mittlerweile in jedem der kleinen Ecke, irgendwo in der Decke ist irgendwo eine Kamera, die auch eine andere Kamera beobachtet, noch eine Kamera beobachtet. Ist das auch gesetzmäßig verschlimmert worden?
Ja, wir haben ja, also das ist nicht verschlimmert worden, das ist verbessert worden. Es gibt nämlich das Videoüberwachungsverbesserungsgesetz, ein Lieblingsgesetzes Titel, die es überhaupt gibt. Also ich würde es eher Videoüberwachungsvereinfachungsgesetz nennen, weil das Gesetz hat gemacht, eigentlich muss man ja gucken, wenn man eine Videokamera installieren will, zum Beispiel in einem Späti oder sonst irgendwo, dass man eine Abwägung macht zwischen dem Sicherheitsinteresse des Betreibers der Kamera und eben dem Interesse der Person, die da, oder die Massenweisepersonen, die da rumlaufen auf ihre Privatsphäre. Und dieses Gesetz hat es eben einfacher gemacht, diese Kameras aufzuhängen, weil es eben sagt, im Zweifelsfall ist die Abwägung für die Sicherheit, was auch immer diese Sicherheit ist. Da haben wir ja diese gefühlte Sicherheit, weil es gibt ja diverse Studien, die sagen, Kameras tragen nicht wirklich zur Sicherheit bei, weil eine Kamera kann ja keinen Verbrechen verhindern. Aber auf jeden Fall ist es mit diesem Gesetz halt einfacher geworden, jetzt eine Videokamera zu legitimieren. Man sieht natürlich noch viel mehr Kameras, die nicht legitimiert sind. Da kümmert sich aber auch keiner drum. Also meine Favoritenkamera dahingehend war immer noch eine Kamera vor der SPD-Zentrale in Berlin, die ihre Kamera rechtswidrig aufgehängt haben. Das hat dann auch die Datenschutzbeauftragte gesagt. Das war so ein bisschen peinlich. Aber ansonsten gerade so polizeiliche Videoüberwachung ist ein Thema, das die Länder regeln. Und da haben wir in Berlin, das ist momentan, ja, das ist einer meiner liebsten Bündnisse, die ich kenne. Das ist das Bündnis für mehr Videoaufklärung und mehr Datenschutz. Die setzen sich gerade dafür ein, dass man in Berlin mehr Videoüberwachung von der Polizei gemacht bekommen darf. Und die haben ganz abstruse Vorstellungen. Das heißt, die wollen auf jeden Fall mehr Videoüberwachung. Sie wollen die Daten aus der Videoüberwachung länger speichern. Sie haben dafür eine ganz großartige Begründung, nämlich sie sagen, wenn man die Daten länger speichert, also einen Monat lang in ihrem Fall oder in ihrem Vorschlag, dann ist das Datenschutz schonend, weil nämlich dann die Polizei ja erst mal was anderes machen kann und anders ermitteln kann, bevor sie die Bilder anguckt. Sie muss nämlich dann keine Angst haben, dass die Bilder gelöscht werden, bevor sie auf die Idee kommen, die anzugucken. Also es ist aber Landesgesetzgebung. Das versuchen sie gerade zu beeinflussen. Aber das ist ein großartiges Ding, kann man sich mal angucken.
Gibt es denn da irgendwie, weil du gerade gesagt hast, es gibt viele rechtswidrig aufgehängte Kameras, keiner kümmert sich drum, gibt es denn da sowas wie, also ich habe, es gibt einen Leitfaden in irgendeinem Blog, wo wenn ein Auto auf dem Radweg parkt, was man dann genau machen muss, wie man die Polizei anruft, was man da sagt und so weiter und so fort, gibt es sowas für Kameras auch, die man in öffentlichen Raum sieht?
Na ja, da geht man zu seinem Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten und sagt hier guck mal, das ist eine Kamera, die soll da nicht sein oder beziehungsweise zum Beispiel, die ist nicht gekennzeichnet oder die Kamera guckt auf den Straßenraum. Das heißt, es ist ja teilweise okay, wenn Geschäftsbetreiber Kameras vor ihrem Geschäft aufhängen, wenn die dann wirklich diesen Geschäftsbereich filmen und die ordentlich gekennzeichnet sind. Aber meistens hat man das halt so, dass die Kamera dann eben auf den Bürgersteig guckt. Und da kann man dann sagen, hier bitte überprüft das mal. Und dann ist das Prozedere, das dauert dann meistens so ein halbes, dreiviertel Jahr. Und dann schreibt der, die Datenschutzbeauftragte, einen bösen Brief dahin und sagt, das darf sie aber so nicht machen. Und überprüft das dann vielleicht nochmal. Und dann hat man das Problem vielleicht nicht gelöst, aber zumindest den Leuten mal gesagt, dass sie nicht machen dürfen, was sie wollen.
Okay, aber das ist dann noch ein langwieriges Prozedere und wahrscheinlich auch ein frustrierendes.
Ja, aber ich glaube, wenn das viele Leute machen, wird das halt irgendwann nervig. Also das ist glaube ich ganz gut. Ich glaube, wenn viele Leute dahinschreiben, dann...
Ich habe da so einen ganz interessanten aktuellen Fall. Ich war letztens in der Sauna in Berlin und da war so eine Umkleide. Ja, da habe ich mich so ein bisschen umgeguckt, weil da war so ein Schild, Achtung, W, Überwachung. Ja, in der Umkleide, wo Leute sich nackig machen. Und das fand ich dann, oh Wunder, als Datenschützerin nicht ganz so cool, ne? Also ich meine, in Berlin, halt im Osten, ist halt so FKK-Sauna jetzt nichts Besonderes. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass mich der Betreiber in der Umkleide abfilmen darf, ne? Also nicht ohne Grund darf man halt in solchen Arealen dann halt auch keine Kamera und kein Handy mitnehmen. Ja, und das hab ich dann der Datenschutzbeauftragten in Berlin natürlich gemeldet. Man kennt mich da schon. Und dann hab ich natürlich den Betreiber nochmal angefragt, so ja, ich möchte jetzt das Verfahrensverzeichnis haben. Also du kannst halt schon als Privatperson nach dem derzeitigen Bundesdatenschutzgesetz halt anfragen, hier gib mir mal das Verfahrensverzeichnis.
Was ist ein Verfahrensverzeichnis?
Ja, da stehen so alle wichtigen Dinge drin über, ja, personenbezogene Datenverarbeitung, beispielsweise wer ist die verantwortliche Stelle, wie lange wird es gespeichert und also so gibt's, sag ich mal, so Vorlagen, die man erfüllen muss.
Also ist quasi eine Art Beipackzettel für die jeweilige aufgehängte Kamera.
Genau, den muss man aber extra anfordern, was mega unpraktisch ist und habe ich bis heute natürlich noch nicht bekommen. Das ist jetzt drei Monate her. Also die Beschwerde liegt da auch schon vor. Ich habe da natürlich auch schon angerufen beim Geschäftsführer oder bei dem Unternehmen und die haben mich wahrscheinlich schon gegoogelt. Also die waren halt auch sehr aufgeschlossen und ja, ich meinte halt so, also Entschuldigung, aber es kann doch nicht sein, hier gehen ja auch Kinder hin. Also ich finde es halt, man kann doch nicht irgendwie kindernackig abfilmen. Da ist den Typen dann vollkommen der Kragen geplatzt. Und ich finde, wenn mehr Leute, die so etwas beobachten, da anrufen würden und dem öfter mal der Kragen platzt und man auch mehr beschwerden, also wenn jetzt noch drei, vier Leute über das Warbali-Spa in Berlin eine Beschwerde einlegen würden, dann würde mir das extrem helfen und vielen anderen Menschen auch.
Okay, gut, dann hätten wir das erst mal. Kommen gleich zum ersten, ich sage mal richtigen IT-Gesetz, nämlich zum Gesetz zur Erhöhung der Sicherheit informationstechnischen Systeme dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Vorher haben wir noch eine kleine Musik, die auch unter freier Lizenz im Netz verfügbar ist, um vom Summer 2017 Sampler von Set Tapes kommt. Danach gibt es Nachrichten und Nerd News. Dann hören wir uns wieder. Das Song for French Birds von Trashton zu finden im Netzmusiksempler Summer 2017 von den Z-Tapes Label.
Superradio 3000, wir spielen die größten Super-Mega-Hits aller Zeiten mit der meisten Abwechslung und dem besten von heute im Super-Mega-Mix. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich bin der Jupp Nippenbräusch von Nippenbräusch Kleiderbügel International Unlimited. Ich hab Millionen mit Kleiderbügel gemacht.
Interessant.
Und jetzt steige ich ganz groß in die Politik ein. Und deswegen werde ich eure Sender-Klitscherer kaufen. Ich kaufe die Moderatorin, ich kaufe die Musiker, ich kaufe die Techniker, der ganze Puff. Und dann kaufe ich mir noch ein paar Radiosender, ohne ein paar Fernsehsender, ohne ein paar Zeitungen dazu. Und alle müssen sich gut über mich berichten.
Und dann lasse ich mich wählen. Jetzt spielt keine Rolle.
Verstehe, da verbinde ich sie gerne mal eben mit unserer Marketingabteilung.
Es muss auch Radio- und Fernsehsender geben, die von mächtigen Milliardären und Meinungsmachern unabhängig sind. Unabhängig sind. Und die man nicht kaufen kann.
Fritz ist ein öffentlich-rechtliches Radioprogramm.
Und abhängig sind wir auch.
Aber nur von euch.
Fritz, unabhängig durch euren Rundfunkbeitrag.
Fritz Nachrichten Mit Merlin Schulz.
Nach dem tödlichen Angriff auf jüdische Siedler im Westjordanland hat Israels Ministerpräsident Netanyahu die Todesstrafe für den Attentäter gefordert. Der Regierungschef sagte, die Zeit für die Todesstrafe in Extremfällen sei gekommen. Ein 19-jähriger Palästinenser hatte am vergangenen Freitag drei Israelis in einer jüdischen Siedlung getötet. Das israelische Recht lässt die Todesstrafe zwar zu, seit der Gründung des Staates wurde sie aber nur einmal angewendet. Nach dem starken Regen in den vergangenen Tagen ist die Hochwasserlage in Mitteldeutschland weiter angespannt. Die Gemeinde Haasleben im Harz in Sachsen-Anhalt ist nach Angaben der Behörden großflächig überschwemmt. Einige Anwohner mussten mit Schlauchbooten aus ihren Häusern gerettet werden. Im benachbarten Langenstein droht ein Erdrutsch. In Niedersachsen hat sich die Lage etwas entspannt. In Goslar konnte der Katastrophenalarm aufgehoben werden. Studierende der Berliner Beuth-Hochschule haben heute für eine neue Kindertagesstätte auf dem Campus demonstriert. Damit wollten die Studenten das Bezirksamt Mitte auffordern, dem Neubau zuzustimmen. Der Bedarf ist groß, ungefähr jeder zehnte Student hat Kinder. Die Räume der vorhandenen Kita wurden zum Jahresende gekündigt. Die Kapazitäten sind außerdem bereits jetzt nicht mehr ausreichend. In der Nähe von Frankfurt Oder hat das Helene Beach Festival begonnen. Der tagelange Regen in Brandenburg hatte die Anreise etlicher Besucher verzögert und den Aufbau erschwert, wie die Organisatoren mitteilten. Straßen und Wege mussten verdichtet und Wasser abgepumpt werden. Das Musikfestival dauert bis zum Sonntag. Rund 120 Künstler sollen auf sieben Bühnen auftreten. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Charlottenburg 18 Grad, Marzahn 19 Grad, Brück 15 Grad, Feikensee 17 Grad, in Forst und Prenzlau sind es aktuell 18 Grad. Am Abend und in der Nacht kann es vor allem im Süden noch schauern und gewittern, sonst bleibt es trocken. Der Freitag bringt Wolken und ein paar Schauer. Im Laufe des Tages lässt sich auch mal die Sonne blicken. Das Ganze bei Höchstwerten von 23 Grad in Berlin und 24 Grad in Brandenburg. A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Brandenburg und Netzen gibt es Behinderungen wegen eines Unfalls. Vorsicht auf der A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Spreeau. Zwischen Genshagen und Rangsdorf liegen Gegenstände auf der rechten Spur. Vorsicht noch mal auf der A10 nördlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Havelland. Zwischen Birkenwerder und Mühlenberg kommt es zu Behinderungen wegen einer Unfallaufnahme auf der linken Spur. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Werder. Zwischen Dreieck Nutetal und Raststätte Michendorf wird ein Unfall auf der linken Spur im Kurvenbereich aufgenommen. Fahrt da bitte vorsichtig. Vorsicht auch auf der A115 Zubringer Nutetal Richtung Berlin zwischen Samund und Potsdam-Drewitz gibt es Behinderungen wegen eines Unfalls. Und Vorsicht im Kreis Uckermark auf der L284 zwischen Flimsdorf und Fecho befindet sich ein Rehbock auf der Fahrbahn. Allen unterwegs und da, wo es geht. Nur gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RWB.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash tips.
Ihr hört das Chaosradio im Blue Moon of Fritz. Das ist nicht gelbe, gelbe ist die Nerd-News nicht. Die geschrieben wurden von Mo und präsentiert werden von Merlin Schulz.
Petja entschlüsselt. Opfer der Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner Bisha Petja und Golden Eye können aufatmen. Der Hersteller hat den Master Schlüssel veröffentlicht und es gibt bereits eine Entschlüsselungstool. Wenn man die verschlüsselte Festplatte noch besitzt, kann man die Daten wieder herstellen. Für Daten, die vom Trojaner Not Petja verschlüsselt wurden, gibt es noch keinen Master Schlüssel. Staatstrojaner noch 2017. Das Bundeskriminalamt will noch in diesem Jahr sein Staatstrojaner RCIS erweitern, um Smartphones zu hacken und Messenger mitzulesen. Das geht aus einem geheimen Bericht des Innenministeriums hervor, den netzpolitik.org in der letzten Woche veröffentlicht hat. Darüber hinaus hat das BKA auch noch die Spionage-Software FinSpy in der Hinterhand zum Zwecke der Redundanz. Diese Software der Firma Gamma wird vornehmlich in Schurkenstaaten eingesetzt, um Oppositionelle auszuspionieren. Sie kann weit mehr als das Gesetz erlaubt. Verbraucherzentrale verklagt Media Markt. Die Verbraucherzentrale NRW verklagt Media Markt, weil sie ein Smartphone mit Sicherheitslücken verkauft haben. Auf den betroffenen Geräten des Herstellers Movistel wurden vom Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik 15 Sicherheitslücken identifiziert. Sie können durch ein Update nicht behoben werden. Weil sich der Hersteller zu den Vorwürfen nicht äußerte, soll nun der Verkäufer verklagt werden, da er der unmittelbare Vertragspartner der Käufer sei. Es handele sich um einen Präzedenzfall, so die Verbraucherzentrale. EuGH schützt Fluggastdaten. Der Europäische Gerichtshof hat das geplante Abkommen zum Austausch von Fluggastdaten mit Kanada gestopft. Es darf in seiner jetzigen Form nicht geschlossen werden, weil es gegen europäische Grundrechte verstößt. Die weitergegebenen Daten verraten zu viel über die Fluggäste und ihr Privatleben. Datenschützer fordern, dass auch die bestehenden Abkommen mit den USA und Australien und die neue EU-Richtlinie zu Fluggastdatenspeicherung gerichtlich geprüft werden müssen.
Merlin Schulz präsentiert den J-News. Vielen Dank, wenn ihr selber nachlesen wollt. Die Links gibt's nach der Sendung auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Das Chaosradio im Blumen. Heute ein Rückblick auf die politische Arbeit der Regierung und vielleicht auch der Opposition in der letzten Legislaturperiode, wenn es um die digitalen Sachen geht. Zu Gast sind Katharina, Christian und Anna. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück nochmal. Und wir beschäftigen uns mit den Gesetzen, die so im Laufe der letzten Jahre im Neuland erlassen wurden und kommen jetzt zum Gesetz zur Erhöhung der Sicherheit informationstechnischer Systeme, dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Wenn ich mir jetzt das nochmal durch den Kopf gehen lasse, was dieser Titel mir sagt, wo ich sage, geil, die Regierung hat endlich angefangen zu sagen, das wäre doch eigentlich gut, wenn niemand in unsere Rechner, also unsere informationstechnische Systeme einbricht und die müssen geschützt werden, vor allen Akteuren, vor allen Dingen auch vor der Regierung selbst. Aber wahrscheinlich stand das nicht da drin.
Nee, in dem Gesicht, äh, nicht in dem Gesicht, in dem Selbststand stand erstmal gar nicht so viel wirklich Revolutionäres drin. Da stand mehr oder weniger drin, dass IT-Sicherheitsvorfälle gemeldet werden müssen, nämlich dem BSI, also dem Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Das, was man damit wollte, ist ein sogenanntes Lagebild zu haben, um eben einen Überblick darüber zu haben, welche IT-Sicherheitsvorfälle es denn so gibt.
Aber jetzt also nicht jeder Einzelne, sondern Firmen oder wie?
Genau, ja, ja, klar, große Firmen. Und da war das halt so ein bisschen das Problem, dass dieses Gesetz extrem beschränkt war auf die sogenannten kritischen Infrastrukturen. Das heißt, es geht ja nicht mal wirklich um Firmen, sondern es geht um Apparate, die so groß sind, dass wenn sie ausfallen würden, dass dann Deutschland ein Problem hätte. Das kann zum Beispiel ein Krankenhaus sein, das kann Energieversorger sein, das kann der Wasserversorger sein, was auch immer. Und dann muss man sich halt fragen, die Meldepflicht war anonym. Das heißt, da ist jetzt kein Imageverlust. Genau, da ist jetzt kein Imageverlust zu befürchten, wenn man das so ein bisschen verkackt hat. Und da stand auch nur drin, man muss Vorkehrungen zur IT-Sicherheit treffen, die dem aktuellen Stand der Technik entsprechen. Das heißt, es war maximal unkonkret. Also man soll mal versuchen, das so gut wie möglich zu machen. Und wenn man es halt nicht schafft, dann soll man es anonym ans BSI melden. Und dann schauen wir mal weiter.
Was heißt anonym melden? Das heißt, ich muss nicht sagen, wer das meldet, aber ich muss schon einen Namen reinschreiben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das genau läuft. Auf jeden Fall müssen sie eigentlich nicht sagen, wer sie sind. Und dann das Lustige daran ist, ich fand das halt auch super absurd. Und dann habe ich mal einen Menschen, der dafür mitverantwortlich ist, gefragt, sag mal, was soll denn das? Also es gibt so Ausnahmen von dieser anonymen Meldepflicht. Und dann meinte ich so, was soll denn das? Wann ist denn dann die Meldepflicht nicht mehr anonymen? Das heißt, wann muss denn dein Name sagen? Und dann meinte er tatsächlich sehr trocken zu mir, naja, also das wäre dann in besonders schweren Fällen. Also wenn zum Beispiel das Licht überall ausgeht, dann merken sie ja eh, welcher Stromversorger betroffen war. Und das war dann so ein bisschen, naja, okay.
Ich muss noch mal nachfragen. Das heißt, man sagt nicht mal, der Firma so und so ist, was passiert. Und man weiß sozusagen dann nicht, wer es gemeldet hat, sondern anonym auch im Sinne, irgendwo gab es irgendeine Sicherheitslücke?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Verfahren genau ist. Das steht ja nicht im Gesetz so genau drin, wie dann diese Abläufe sind, dass du ans BSI melden musst. Aber das Problem ist halt, wenn man über dieses Lagebild hat, dass das das BSI hat. Und das BSI will damit natürlich andere warnen. Das heißt, da kommt dann eine Meldung rein, von wegen wir haben jetzt bösen Verschlüsselungs-Drojaner XY, und dann sagt das BSI all den anderen, die halt auch wichtig sind, hier guckt mal, da kommt was, schaut mal, dass ihr eure Systeme absichert. Aber das Problem ist ja eigentlich, wenn man ja auch die Öffentlichkeit informieren. Und das wird mit diesem Ding kaum möglich sein. Oder halt nur mangelhaft. Oder einfach nur mit Informationen, die nicht besonders befriedigend ist.
Jetzt ist es ja häufig so, wenn Gesetze so maximal unkonkret sind, dann kommt das daher, dass sie in langen Sitzungen erbittert auseinandergenommen, wieder zusammengesetzt wurden, an so ein Kompromissding sind. Ist das in dem Fall auch so, dass sich da verschiedene Parteien sozusagen miteinander bekriegt haben? Oder ist das einfach so, wir machen das jetzt mal so, weil wir wollen es der Wirtschaft auch nicht so schwer machen und da hat doch gar keiner widersprochen?
Ich glaube, mit dem Stand der Technik ist es tatsächlich auch ein Updateproblem für die Gesetzgebung. Denn so schnell, wie sich sozusagen technische Systeme entwickeln können, kommt der Gesetzgeber gar nicht mit Verordnungen und Gesetzen hinterher. Und deswegen verwendet man diesen Begriff generell, wenn es um IT-Sicherheit geht. Das hat man ja auch im Telemediengesetz, im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz gemacht, wo man das erste Mal geschäftsmäßige Telemediendienstanbieter, also zum Beispiel Internetseitenbetreiber, verpflichtet hat, auch IT-Sicherheit zu implementieren, selbst wenn keine personenbezogenen Daten vorgehalten werden.
Ja, aber ich sehe das irgendwie ein bisschen problematischer, weil man kann schon sagen, irgendwie Stand der Technik, aber man kann nicht komplett nicht sagen, was das sein muss. Da muss man irgendeine Art von Vorschrift haben. Wir haben ja auch zum Beispiel irgendwelche BSI-Empfehlungen, wie man seine Systeme sicher macht. Und dann könnte man ja zumindest sagen, die werden ja geupdated. Ihr müsst mindestens dem entsprechen. Und wenn man nicht mal sagt, was ihr tun müsst und dann nicht mal eine wirksame Sanktionierung hat, wenn man das nicht macht, dann ist dieses Gesetz quasi eigentlich nur das Papier, auf dem es steht. Also man hatte am Anfang in diesem Gesetz irgendwie nicht mal drinnen, dass es sanktioniert werden kann. Da wurde dann immer gesagt, die Branchen sollen sich selber aussuchen, wie sie das machen. Und dann gab es ganz viel Kritik. Und da haben wir gesagt, das kann doch nicht sein. So ist doch ein Witz. Und dann haben sie gesagt, okay, dann sanktionieren wir halt doch. Und dann gibt es so Sanktionierungen, die Kosten. Also wenn man dann irgendwas verkackt hat, dann muss man 50.000 bis 100.000 Euro Strafe zahlen, was jetzt eventuell auch nicht so viel ist.
Also ich glaube, einen echten Anreiz wird es erst geben, wenn jeder Nutzer und vielleicht die Verbraucherzentrale das mal durchpauchen würde, dass wirklich bei gravierenden Sicherheitsmängeln, bei denen ich persönlich betroffen bin, ich persönlich auch klagen kann. Und vielleicht nicht nur ich persönlich, sondern viele andere Betroffene. Dadurch erhöht sich natürlich das Pain-Potenzial, wenn man wirklich beispielsweise wirklich Nachlässigkeit nachweisen kann und handeln wieder besseres Wissen, dass man da auch dafür ordentlich latzen muss. Weil im Endeffekt muss man ja auch das so sehen, dass bei vielen größeren Unternehmen, sage ich mal jetzt nicht mittelständischen IT-Unternehmen, sondern sage ich mal bestimmt ja eher der Shareholder Value, wohin die Reise geht und weniger, sage ich mal, das Gewissen eines einzelnen Gründers vielleicht, der sagt, so können wir das aber nicht machen. Und da würde ich sagen, also natürlich ist eine Meldung irgendwie ganz interessant, spannend, ich glaube aber wirklich eine Veränderung im Bereich IT-Sicherheit hast du halt erst, wenn du wirklich irgendwo Haftung einführst.
Ja, das kann ich auf jeden Fall unterstreichen. Die Möglichkeit gibt es allerdings schon. Es ist interessant, dass das in Deutschland nicht genutzt wird, während wir gerade in Amerika eigentlich schon Millionen Klagen haben, die bisher immer mit Vergleichen endeten, wenn es zu großen Data Breaches kommt. Aber juristisch kann ich sagen, ist das eine Pflichtverletzung? Also nach unterschiedlichen Gesetzen. Und ich kann Schadensersatz verlangen, wenn ich einen Verstoß auch gegen IT-Sicherheitsvorstiften nachweisen kann.
Da freue ich mich auch auf die EU-Datenschutz-Grundverordnung. Da sollen ja die Meldepflichten ausgeweitet werden. Weil meistens ist es ja so, dass, sage ich mal, große Sicherheitsmängel meistens nur dem kleinen elitären Kreis, der Heiseläser vorbehalten bleiben. Und sage ich mal, viele bekommen es einfach nicht mit. Und wenn es dann wirklich so ist, dass ich benachrichtigt werden muss von meinem Anbieter, ich glaube, da wird es ganz vielen Leuten auch schon mal flau im Magen werden, wenn die Playstation beispielsweise mal wieder schludrig mit meinen Daten um sich schnüffeln.
Also, das melde ich nicht nur im Sinne von, ich muss den BSI oder irgendeinem anders melden, sondern ich muss zum User hingehen und sagen so, pass auf, leider ist da was kaputt gegangen. Okay, ich habe mal noch sozusagen eine generelle Metaebenenfrage. Also, eine Einschätzung von euch, nämlich was ihr glaubt, was das Verständnis der Politik überhaupt von so digitalen Software-Systemen ist. Weil ich habe den Eindruck immer, wenn man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt, weiß man, Software hat Fehler. Also, das ist grundsätzlich so. Und Software ist ein System, das immer wieder gewartet werden muss. Also, wo man Updates machen und Sicherheitslücken beseitigen muss. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Gesetzgebung immer so in so einem Produktdenken verhaftet ist. Also quasi, dass wenn der Kunde das dann kauft, dann ist das auch seins, dann muss er sich irgendwie drum kümmern. Und das ist ja auch was Firmen dann gerne machen, die Verantwortung abwälzen, sagen, du betreibst die Software ja, wir sind da gar nicht mehr zuständig. Ist bei der Politik schon diese grundsätzliche Idee davon, was Software ist, angekommen? Also reden da schon Leute darüber, die Ahnung davon haben?
Das kann ich jetzt allgemein nicht beantworten, aber ich glaube, der Stand der Technik verweist ja auch gerade sozusagen auf Update Pflichten. Und ich glaube, was zumindest langsam durchsickert ist, dass die Hersteller auch in die Verantwortung genommen werden müssten, wirklich auch Updates anzubieten. Ich glaube, das ist der Lernprozess, der gerade stattfindet, auch sozusagen mit der Regulierung des ominösen Internets der Dinge. Aber ich glaube, dass mit dieser Update, Update Pflicht und der Fehlbarkeit von Software ist wahrscheinlich was, was im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz auch schon in gewissem Rahmen berücksichtigt wurde.
Kann man da eigentlich sagen, also wenn man jetzt die letzten vier Jahre beobachtet, kann man da so klare Linien ziehen? Also gibt es bei sowas wie Update Pflicht auch konservative Liberale und Linke oder sowas? Also ich würde mir jetzt vorstellen, es gibt vielleicht so jemand, wie die FDP, der sagt so Nein, die Firmen haben damit nichts zu tun. Die müssen ihre Investitionen sozusagen. Das wäre eine viel zu große Belastung. Und alle anderen sagen aber so Nee, eigentlich schon eine gute Idee, dass sie das müssen. Oder gibt es da noch mehr Linien? Und gibt es da überhaupt so eine klaren Lager?
Na, ich glaube, dass niemand wird sagen, dass es jetzt irgendwie schlecht ist, wenn Leute ihre Systeme updaten müssen und wenn IT-Sicherheit sichergestellt wird. Aber ich glaube, die Gewichtungen verschieben sich. Weil gerade bei diesem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz hatte man gerade diese anonyme Meldepflicht dadurch so stark, dass die Unternehmen und bzw. die betroffenen Betreiber von den kritischen Infrastrukturen massiv lobbyiert haben. Also hat man natürlich Unternehmensinteressen. Und da gibt es dann immer die Leute, die mit ihren schicken Lobbypapieren hingehen und sagen so Hey, das könnt ihr aber nicht machen. Das ist ja nicht so gut für uns. Und das ganze Zeug mit der IT-Sicherheit, das kostet ja so viel Geld. Das passiert ja sowieso nicht.
Aber wo gehen die hin?
Na die gehen dann zu den entsprechenden Ministerien, die die Gesetzesentwürfe vorbereiten.
Aber das ist parteienunabhängig.
Das ist erst mal parteienunabhängig, klar. Die gehen auch im Zweifelsfall zu jedem. Die gehen erst mal in die Ministerien, solange die Gesetze erarbeitet werden. Wenn die Gesetze vom Kabinett beschlossen sind, gehen sie halt in den Bundestag und labern die Abgeordneten an. Also das ist halt einfach so ein ewiger Kreislauf. Und dann versuchen sie, den klar zu machen. So wenn ihr das macht, ist aber die deutsche Wirtschaft irgendwie ganz böse dran. Und dann bringt man natürlich seine Interessen unter. Aber es wird natürlich keine der Parteien hingehen und sagen, wir brauchen die IT-Sicherheit nicht.
Na ja, das ist ja alles für die Sicherheit. Weil wenn andere die Sicherheitslücken kennen, dann ist es ja umso gefährlicher. Das ist ja ein beliebtes Argument.
Außerdem, ich glaube, man hat so ein bisschen zwischen den Parteien verschobene Wahrnehmung von, was müssen wir jetzt eigentlich machen? Müssen wir jetzt die IT-Sicherheit stärken oder müssen wir die Leute, die die IT-Sicherheit kaputt machen, bestrafen? Wir haben ja immer dieses...
Beides?
Ja, aber ich glaube, die Schwerpunkte sind anders. Weil wenn man jetzt mal so konservativ rankuckt, dann sagt man einfach, wir machen ganz, ganz böse Strafen für die Leute, die die Systeme kaputt machen. Und dann halten wir die davon ab. Oder wir machen halt die Systeme so sicher, dass Leute das vielleicht gar nicht mehr so erfolgreich machen können. Und da hören sie ja nicht mal auf ihre eigenen Behörden, weil zumindest das BSI, das ja, sag ich mal, Ahnung davon haben sollte, sagt ja die ganze Zeit, Leute benutzt Open-Source-Software. Dann wäre einiges nicht passiert, aber irgendwie hält sich keiner dran.
Nice. Warum auf Experten hören? Das hat sich noch nie bewährt. Jetzt gab es beim IT-Sicherheitsgesetz auch, da läuft jetzt auch die Vorratsleitspeicherung. Über den Weg.
Die war im Telemediengesetz angelegt. Es sollte da quasi eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt werden. Aber nach der öffentlichen Konsultation, und ich glaube, der Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat eine wichtige Rolle gespielt, wurde das dann aus dem Gesetzentwurf Ende 2014 herausgenommen.
Gibt es da so eine freiwillige Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Ja, da gab es ja mal so viel Spaß und Freude um ein Dokument, das mal aufgetaucht ist. Vor Jahren war ich noch beim VZBV, also bei der Verbraucherzentrale. Und da wurde mal aufgeschlüsselt, was eigentlich die Polizeibehörden bei den einzelnen Internetdienstleistern beispielsweise abgreifen dürfen. Da wurde klar so hoch, wir haben ja bei vielen Anbietern eine freiwillige Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und jetzt ist es so, dass, also danach gab es einen langen Prozess von, sag ich mal, Streit und Diskussion und Treffen mit dem Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten, dem ehemaligen. Und der wollte das so ein bisschen minimieren. Es ist allerdings so, dass, sag ich mal, vom gesetzlichen Her natürlich es Anbieter gibt, die sich gerne bei der freiwilligen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also beispielsweise bei Logdaten bis in alle Ewigkeit darauf berufen, so ja, das hat natürlich Sicherheitsinteressen. Das ist in der Praxis bei einigen Webseitenbetreiber natürlich eher um Werbeinteressen geht. Lassen wir mal dahingestellt sein. Aber im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz war unter anderem auch, sag ich mal, noch mal eine Festschreibung und eine Ausweitung dieser freiwilligen Vorratsdatenspeicherung aus Sicherheitsgründen.
Also was man da darf, ohne es zu müssen.
Genau, was man dann freiwillig macht. Und da muss man eben ganz klar sagen, also die meisten Unternehmen, die irgendwas mit personenbezogenen Daten zu tun haben, denen ist halt klar, wir können das irgendwann zu Geld machen. Wir können das halt eben nicht nur in anonymisierter Form nutzen, sondern vielleicht auch für Direktmarketing und so weiter. Ich möchte da niemandem was unterstellen, aber da gibt es eben auch ganz viele schwarze Schafe, die solch eine Lücke eben nicht nur für die Sicherheitsinteressen ausnutzen werden.
Wie ist denn jetzt der aktuelle Stand eigentlich bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Das ist kompliziert.
Natürlich. Warum auch? Warum heißt das auch einfach?
Ich glaube, vielleicht fangen wir mal mit dem aktuellen Stand an, um das von hinten aufzurollen. Also momentan ist der Stand so, dass die Bundesnetzagentur, die dafür zuständig ist, eigentlich zu kontrollieren, dass die Betreiber speichern und wie sie das tun, ob sie das sicher tun und so weiter, gesagt hat, dass...
Aber es gibt momentan Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Es gibt ein Gesetz, dass das sagt...
Es gibt ein Gesetz, das sagt, wir haben am 1. Juli, müsst ihr eigentlich alles speichern. Also ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Und jetzt aber die Bundesnetzagentur gesagt, na ja, ihr müsst zwar alles speichern, aber wenn ihr es nicht macht, bestrafen wir euch nicht. Das klingt ein bisschen schizophräen. Und das Ganze hat damit zu tun, dass mehrere Leute gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung geklagt haben, unter anderem ein bestimmter Provider. Und der hat so ein bisschen einen anderen Weg eingeschlagen als alle anderen. Der ist nämlich nicht vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht gegangen, sondern vor ein Verwaltungsgericht. Weil der hat gesagt, ich will aus diversen Gründen keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Das verzehrt zum Beispiel meinen Wettbewerb, weil manche anderen in Europa das ja auch nicht wissen. Und dann gehen die Kunden nicht zu mir. Oder das ist ein extremer Aufwand. Oder auch, das ist eben nicht mit EU-Recht vereinbar. Und dann hat er noch mal einen Eilantrag gestellt. Der wurde erst mal abgelehnt, aber dann doch bewilligt. Und dann hat das Gericht irgendwie das Oberverwaltungsgericht in Münster hat dann gesagt, wir halten die Vorratsdatenspeicherung für europarechtswidrig. Deshalb musst du erst mal nicht speichern, bis das Hauptverfahren vorbei ist. Das ist alles super kompliziert. Das heißt, nicht mal sein Hauptverfahren ist vorbei. Danach haben aber ganz viele gesagt so, naja, wenn der nicht speichern muss, dann warum müssen wir denn speichern? Und alles sieht so ein bisschen danach aus, als würde das Gesetz gekippt. Aber das muss wiederum das Bundesverfassungsgericht machen. Und das kann kein Verwaltungsgericht machen. Das heißt, da geht noch einiges hin und her. Aber ich sag mal, es sieht meiner Meinung nach ganz doll schlecht für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung aus.
Aber wir haben eine. Und sie kommt aus dieser Legislaturperiode.
Sie kommt aus dieser Legislaturperiode.
Wer hat sie beschlossen?
Na ja, die große Koalition.
Alle?
Bis auf zwei von der SPD oder?
Ja, Marco Bülow hat dagegen gestimmt. Der ist vor der Abstimmung noch zu uns in den Regen rausgekommen zur Demo.
Die haben die also wieder eingeführt, was ja der zweite Versuch ist. Also die ist ja schon mal sozusagen versucht eingeführt zu worden. Das hat ja dann nicht so doll geklappt. Aber vielleicht können wir an dem Punkt tatsächlich schon mal ein bisschen auf die Parteien eingehen und vielleicht auch jetzt schon in die Zukunft gucken. Habe ich mir gerade überlegt. Also CDU und SPD haben dafür gestimmt. Ist das immer noch so, dass sozusagen bei beiden Parteien große Zustimmung ist für Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder lehnen die sie jetzt so zurück und man hat so das Gefühl, die lassen das jetzt in der EU scheitern, das ist dann auch okay in das Thema gegessen. Oder gibt es da noch so richtig Leute, die wollen diese Internetdatenüberwachung?
Na, ich finde es super witzig, weil wenn man sich mal die Wahlprogramme anschaut, was sie ja so fordern, dann sind CDU und SPD die Einzigen, die sich nicht zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung äußern. Oh. Das ist ziemlich bezeichnend, weil sie ja gemerkt haben, sie wollten das unbedingt haben. Also eigentlich wollte die SPD das ja offiziell nicht haben, weil Justizminister Maas hat ja gesagt, mit uns wird es keine Alleingangsvorratsdatenspeicherung in Europa geben. Zwei Wochen später war das dann wieder gegessen und dann hat er doch eine gemacht. Aber auf jeden Fall äußern sie sich halt gerade nicht mehr dazu, weil sie gemerkt haben, wie sehr sie sich quasi in den, sag ich mal in den Dreck gesetzt haben damit und wie verbrannt dieses Thema gerade ist.
Das ist einfach nix. Christian, ihr habt ja beim Humboldt-Institut findet die Gesellschaft ein, wie heißt das, digitaler Wahlkompass?
Genau, Wahlkompass Digitales, ja.
Wo ihr euch da genau mit diesen Themen beschäftigt haben, also was dann sozusagen für die nächste Wahl versprochen wird. CDU und SPD sagen dazu anscheinend gar nichts. Kann man da vielleicht wenigstens zwischen den Zeilen rauslesen, ob die da vielleicht eine Meinung zu haben oder?
Im Wahlprogramm der CDU-CSU ist sozusagen relativ breit aufgeführt, wie viel die für die Sicherheit getan haben in der letzten Legislaturperiode. Und da könnte man das vielleicht zwischen den Zeilen lesen. Bei der SPD ist mir jetzt nichts aufgefallen.
Also zwischen den Zeilen, wir finden das schon so gut. Wie ist es denn bei der Opposition, bei der jetzigen?
Die Kleinparteien haben sich alle dagegen geäußert. Die Linke grundsätzlich, die Grünen und die FDP machen Gegenvorschläge. Die Grünen schlagen eben vor, eine Berichtspflicht einzuführen.
Also sie wollen eine Vorzeitenspeicherung, aber unter anderem Voraussetzungen.
Genau. Und die Hürden für die Abfragen zu erhöhen. Und die FDP hat einen ganz spannenden Vorschlag. Die sagen nämlich, eine Strafverfolgungsbehörde kann sozusagen eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung anfordern. Dann werden die Daten aber erstmal eingefroren, in Anführungszeichen, auch im Wahlprogramm. Und ein unabhängiges Gericht kann die Daten dann auftauen und den Ermittlern zur Verfügung stellen. Also die wollen sozusagen da einen gerichtlichen Prozess dazwischen schalten.
Also Vorratsdatenspeicherung anfordern, das heißt aber sozusagen, es wird erstmal nicht gespeichert und erst wenn jemand sagt, jetzt aber, dann wird es ab dann wird in dem Fall.
Nennt sich Quick Freeze, deshalb auch wieder auftauen.
Genau, Quick Freeze. Und die Linke fehlt da glaube ich noch? Welche Verteilen habt ihr überhaupt drin? Ich bin gerade überrascht, FDP, FDP ist gar nicht im Bundestag. Wieso ist die in eurem Kompass drin?
Genau.
Glaubt ihr, die zieht wieder ein?
Wir haben eine Methodik entwickelt und uns eben Wahlprognosen des letzten Jahres angeschaut. Also von 2016 und wenn irgendeine Partei zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt mal über 5% war, in einer bestimmten Prognose, dann haben wir sie aufgenommen. Das heißt CDU, CSU, SPD, FDP, die Linke und die AfD haben wir untersucht.
Ja, was sagt denn die Linke?
Die Linke sagt ziemlich klar, sie wollen keine verdachtsunabhängige Datenspeicherung und kein Profiling. Also sie sprechen sich grundsätzlich gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung aus.
Und sind da die einzigen?
Also die anderen sind auch dagegen. Die FDP hat eben diesen Zwischenvorschlag.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn jemand sagt, wir sind dagegen, aber hier haben wir noch einen Vorschlag, dann ist man ja nicht so doll dagegen, oder?
Ja, obwohl, QuickFree ist jetzt nicht als Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist laut meiner Definition immer eine Massenüberwachung, wo ich erstmal alles einsacke und dann gucke ich später mal so, hat sich das denn überhaupt wieder gelohnt? Und QuickFree ist ja schon etwas, da muss ich ja einen gezielten Verdacht haben. Und da muss ich auch zum Richter hingehen und ihm gezielt Beweise vorlegen, warum das jetzt legitim ist. Und dann muss jemand gezielt entscheiden, okay, bei dieser Person wollen wir das jetzt anfangen. Da würde ich halt schon noch mal ein bisschen unterscheiden.
Okay, sehe ich als Punkt. Aber was ich mich frage ist, was bei der Vorzeitenspeicherung war ja einst Argumente ähnlich wie bei den Mautkameras auch. Nämlich, da wird eine Infrastruktur geschaffen, die man dann möglicherweise auch missbrauchen oder ausbauen kann. Jetzt ist ja, wenn man dieses QuickFree anbauen will, da muss man ja auch wieder Infrastruktur schaffen. Und dann ist ja schon der erste Schritt gegangen. Ist das auch eine Argumentation, die gemacht wird?
Na ja, Infrastruktur muss man ja eigentlich nicht schaffen, weil die Provider speichern ja sowieso für sich selbst erst mal einen gewissen Zeitraum. Das heißt, die speichern ja erst mal Daten zur Störungsbehebung. Das heißt, wenn die irgendwie merken, da ist irgendwas in der Leitung, wir müssen mal gucken, woran das liegt, dann können die ja gucken. Die Fristen sind unterschiedlich. Die sind teilweise ein halbes Jahr, was so ein bisschen absurd ist, aber teilweise eben auch nur wenige Tage, um diese Daten zu beheben. Und wenn dann in der Zeit was passiert, das heißt, dann kommt ein böser Attentäter und macht einen Anschlag, dann geht man halt hin und sagt hier, stopp, die Daten würde nicht löschen. Und das ist ja keine großartige Infrastruktur. Das macht ja einfach nur mehr Aufwand für die Ermittlungsbehörden, die dann nicht einfach pauschal abgreifen können.
Und das ist auch ein sozusagen unter Netzaktivisten anerkannte Vorschlag? Also oder nicht kritisierter Vorschlag, mal so gesagt?
Im einzelnen Findes entscheidet sich das immer an den Definitionen, was ist eine Voraussetzung für Überwachung. Das gilt ja für alle Überwachungsmaßnahmen, sei es jetzt Telefon abhören oder Wohnraum abhören und so weiter und so fort. Im Endeffekt ist da die Frage, ab wo ist der Punkt, wo ich, sag ich mal, so weit in den Kernbereich der privaten Lebensgestaltung reingehen kann, dass ich über Vorratsdaten beispielsweise nachverfolgen kann, wann jemand nachts nicht pennen konnte und Zigaretten an der Tanke geholt hat oder ob derjenige halt noch eine Affäre hat. Ob das jetzt beim Handtaschendiebstahl der Fall ist, da würden Datenschützer, sag ich mal, durch die Bankwerk ihre Zweifel haben. Beim Mord, muss ich persönlich sagen, kann ich nachvollziehen, dass man halt so Daten abfragt. Aber andererseits finde ich das auch legitim, dass man sagt, jedem Menschen sollte freistehen, einen Anbieter zu wählen, der beispielsweise sofort löscht, was ich persönlich präferiere. Und da muss die Polizei eben gucken, wie sie damit umgeht. Weil bisher haben wir ja auch, sag ich mal, Verbrechen immer aufgeklärt. Man muss halt eben da gucken, wie weit wollen wir gehen? Und gibt es da nicht auch eine Grenze, die einfach zu überschreitend zu großen gesellschaftlichen Schaden anrichtet?
Würde ich aber denken, wenn man so einen Vorschau wie Quick Freeze macht, dass dann inbegriffen ist, dass ihr da Anbieter das auch umsetzen muss oder nicht?
Ja, in dem Fall schon. Und ich glaube, es hängt auch ganz doll von der richterlichen Kontrolle ab. Man hat ja oft das Problem bei Überwacherungsanordnungen, dass die einfach quasi nicht abgelehnt werden. Dann geht halt die Polizei hin und sagt, hier hätte ich gerne eine Unterschrift und dann kriegt die halt ihre Unterschrift. Und wenn man das kontrollieren kann und das ordentlich aufgezeichnet werden muss, das wäre eine ganz wichtige Voraussetzung. Und natürlich dann eben auch den Straftatenkatalog, für den man das machen darf. Weil noch so eine kleine Randnotiz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung in dem Moment, wo das Oberverwaltungsgericht gesagt hat, so das halten wir irgendwie nicht für rechtens, da hat die Große Koalition noch mal schnell ein Gesetz verabschiedet, das Vorratsdaten auch für Wohnungseinbruchdiebstahl nutzbar gemacht hätte oder faktisch nutzbar macht. Das heißt, sie haben den Strafkartenkatalog noch mal ausgeweitet und irgendwie, Kada meinte ja schon, gerade Handtaschendiebstahl. Also wo setze ich da die Grenze? Geht es dann eben um Mord oder kann ich die Daten abrufen, wenn jemand in eine Wohnung eingebrochen ist? Oder kann ich die Daten abrufen, wenn jemand irgendwie eine Spezie aus einem Späli geklaut hat?
Also ich kann vielleicht noch hier anmerken, ich komme aus Polen und da ist die Grenze halt eben minimal bis nicht Existenz zur Abfrage von Vorratsdaten, was dazu geführt hat, dass so über eine Million abfragen. Pro Jahr hast du, ne? Und so das ist eben auch Teil des Problems. Und ein Jurist hat mir mal einen sehr schönen Witz erzählt. Er meinte so, naja, es gibt keinen Richter, der nicht jederzeit bereit wäre, seine eigene Wohnungsdurchsuchung zu unterzeichnen, weil er es im Zweifel halt eben nicht lesen kann, weil einfach zu viel Überlastung da ist. Und da muss man eben auch aufpassen, dass in vielen, also in den letzten Jahren sehr oft Überwachungsgesetze durchgebracht wurden mit der Standard Balsamierung für Datenschützer. Da ist halt ein Richtervorbehalt, da guckt ja jemand schon drüber. Aber in der Praxis ist das halt oft nicht der Rede wert, leider.
Also nicht im Sinne einer Wahlempfehlung, weil die wollen wir gar nicht geben. Aber wenn man so sagen, dieses eine Thema raufgreift, dann ist aus netzaktivistischer Sicht also Linke, FDP, sonst noch jemand.
Die Grünen äußern sich halt immer so ein bisschen unkonkret. Die Grünen, also in ganz vielen Teilen ihrer Wahlprogramme, wo es um Daten und sowas geht, sagen sie halt immer, wir wollen irgendwie was mit angemessen. Das heißt, die Grünen sagen eigentlich, wir machen im Endeffekt das, was unser Koalitionspartner will. Und auf der anderen Seite bei der Linken muss man halt gucken, dass ihre Forderungen mit keinem Koalitionspartner vereinbaren werden. Das heißt, das, was dann im Endeffekt in einem Regierungsprogramm drinsteht, wird nicht unbedingt das sein, was die Linke fordert.
Verstehe. Dann so viel zum Thema Vorratsan-Speicherung.
Radio hat einen Namen.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück beim Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo wir heute über die Digitalpolitik der letzten vier Jahre sprechen. Zu Gast sind Katharina Nocun. Hallo und guten Abend. Dein offizieller Titel ist eigentlich Digital Aktivistin oder was sagt man?
Äh, gute Frage.
Herzlich willkommen Katharina Nocun. Variiert. Äh, Christian Djefal vom Humboldt Institut für Internet und Gesellschaft.
Genau.
Der am Wahlkompass digital so rum mitgearbeitet hat und Annabie Selje von netzpolitik.org, das dafür bekannt ist, ganz genau hinzugucken, was die Politiker digitalen zu tun haben. Hallo und guten Abend. So, wir haben gerade schon ein bisschen gesprochen über die erste Zeit, dass es sehr lange nichts passiert ist, dass dann sozusagen Gesetze erlassen wurden, die unter anderem mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu tun haben, die wir jetzt schon durchgearbeitet haben. Und ich möchte jetzt diese Gelegenheit, dass die Sendung halb vorbei ist, und ich festgestellt habe, wir haben eine sehr lange Liste, also es ist schon was passiert in den letzten vier Jahren, die wir aber unmöglich in einer weiteren Stunde schaffen können, nach euren politischen Höhepunkten. Ich meine, es ist nicht vielleicht was ihr toll fandet, aber was ihr sozusagen bemerkenswert fandet. Also die letzte Legislaturperiode, was ist da das eine Ding, außer dass Frau Merkel vor der Wahl gesagt hat, dass das in der Neuland ist, auf das ihr euch auf jeden Fall noch erinnern werdet. Katharina, vielleicht können wir mit dir anfangen.
Ja, es gab viele Hoch- und Tiefpunkte. Als ich die Liste hoch durchgegangen bin, waren es halt eher viele Tiefpunkte. Was ich aber nicht vergessen werde, war so eine E-Mail von Edward Snowden, die bei uns irgendwann eingetrudelt ist. Ich habe 2014 bei Campact eine Kampagne geleitet, Asyl für Edward Snowden in Deutschland. Und in dieser E-Mail hat er sich bedankt und hat nochmal bekräftigt, dass er gerne nach Deutschland kommen würde und hat den vielen, vielen Menschen, die ausdauernd, auch nachdem es von den Titelseiten verschwunden ist, nicht nachgegeben haben, nochmal gesagt, weiter so. Das war für mich auf jeden Fall ein total krasser Moment. Und ansonsten mein Tiefpunkt, meine On-Off-Beziehung war so die Vorratsdatenspeise. Weil es für mich ja auch so etwas ist, was mich zur Politik gebracht hat. Und es war auch wirklich rauf und runter wie die schlimmste On-Off-Beziehung, die man sich vorstellen kann. Also erst hurra, Maas äußert sich, er will es nicht machen. Dann kommt das Paris-Attentat, dann kommt Druck von der Parteispitze und dann kommt es doch. Und ja, das war halt so der Abschluss, den ich nie vergessen werde, war halt wirklich der Tag, als das Gesetz verabschiedet wurde. Es hat in Strömen geregnet, alle waren nass bis auf die Knochen. Trotzdem standen wir da vom Bundestag und haben protestiert. Und nur ein einziger Abgeordneter, und zwar Marco Bülow von der SPD, ist rausgekommen. Wir haben alle anderen eingeladen, also bis auf Opposition, klar, aber von den Regierungsvertretern. Und da dachte ich halt wirklich, Scheiße, verkackt. Also wenn man wirklich gegen ein Projekt wirklich jahrelang demonstriert und irgendwie alle möglichen Instanzen sind in Bewegung. Und ja, jetzt dieser Lichtblick durch ein Münsteraler Gericht ist da halt noch mal wieder so ein kleiner Höhepunkt. Und ja, ich bin auch sehr zuversichtlich, dass das Thema uns in der nächsten Legislaturperiode nicht loslassen wird. Also Augen auf bei der Wahlentscheidung, was die Parteien zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung sagen.
Haben wir ja gerade schon geklärt, aber noch mal zu Snowden zurück. Ist eigentlich, was Whistleblower angeht, irgendwas passiert?
Ja, also die Lage hat sich auf gar keinen Fall verbessert. Also es ist nach wie vor so, dass wenn jemand beispielsweise über die illegalen Aktivitäten beim Bundesnachrichtendienst auspacken würde, hätte er ganz schlechte Karten in Deutschland. Es ist nach wie vor so, dass Whistleblower in sehr vielen Bereichen extrem krasse Wege auch auf sich nehmen, um Recht zu bekommen. Also da gibt es ja mehrere prominente Fälle, die bis vor den Europäischen Gerichtshof gegangen sind, beispielsweise von einer Whistleblowerin, die Missstände in der Altenpflege enthüllt hat. So, die musste sich zehn Jahre lang durch alle Instanzen klagen. Und man will sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie viel Mut und auch wie viel Pflichtbewusstsein vielleicht auch so in einem Menschen stecken muss, dass er wirklich alles aufgeht. Also man kann sich vorstellen, da bricht alles für diesen jemand weg. Job, Freunde meistens, man wird öffentlich noch in den Schmutz getreten und man hat eine riesen Anwaltsrechnung. Und von daher nach wie vor nichts passiert, aber natürlich viele große Worte zum Wahlkampf.
Ich glaube, es sind doch zwischendurch so ein Gesetz, wo man dann vermutet, dass dann selbst die Journalisten, die mit geleakten Dokumenten arbeiten.
Jaja, Datenhehlerei.
Genau, Datenhehlerei, das war's. Was war da noch mal genau damit?
Ja, also es war Teil des Paketes zum sogenannten BND-Gesetz. Das ist ja 2016 durchgewunken worden, also im letzten Jahr. Und da war es so, dass dann sogar Journalisten mit ins Visier geraten sind. Und zwar, wenn sie dann beispielsweise vertrauliche Dokumente von Whistleblowern zugeschickt bekommen oder irgendwie weitergeben, dann können sie da eben auch belangt werden.
Anna, wenn ich richtig geguckt habe voran ist, wenn ich jetzt nach Höhepunkt frage, ist BND sowieso ein Thema, oder?
Ja, BND-Gesetz ist natürlich irgendwie der Knaller. Also vor allem, weil wir ja mittlerweile diese ganzen Jahre im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss hinter uns haben, wo eigentlich alle zwei Wochen in der Sitzung immer Donnerstags irgendein neuer Skandal oder zumindest so ein neuer Kopf-auf-Tisch-Platte-Moment kam, was der BND so getrieben hat. Und dann kommt plötzlich noch, bevor diese Untersuchung abgeschlossen ist, ein Gesetz, das eigentlich nix anderes macht, als den ganzen Mist, den der BND gebaut hat, den er damals illegal gemacht hat, oder so. Das ist unter kreativen Rechtsinterpretationen legalisiert. Also das ist schon ein bisschen so ein Schlag ins Gesicht, wo man sich denkt, warum macht man den ganzen Kram eigentlich?
Warum macht man den ganzen Kram? Also das ist tatsächlich was, was ich mich manchmal frage, was Leute sozusagen oder wie sich Leute dazu motivieren, das trotzdem noch weiterzumachen.
Na manches wird ja auch besser oder zumindest nicht schlimmer. Also die Störerhaftung wurde zum Beispiel abgeschafft, sogar zweimal, weil es beim ersten Mal nicht so richtig geklappt hat.
Was war da los?
Na beim ersten Mal waren da immer noch relativ große Lücken drin. Das heißt, eigentlich würden wir dann ja mit Störerhaftung abschaffen, sowas erreichen, wie Leute können ihr WLAN auflassen, ohne dann eben Angst zu haben, abgemahnt zu werden. Da hat man das beim ersten Mal probiert, da waren da Rechtsunsicherheiten drin. Da hat man es noch ein zweites Mal gemacht, vor kurzem erst. Das hat meiner Einschätzung nach einigermaßen funktioniert. Das heißt, ich hätte jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt Angst, abgemahnt zu werden, wenn ich meinen WLAN aufmache. Das Problem ist nur, dass jetzt Inhalteanbieter, die eben Urheberrechtsverletzungen feststellen, noch hingehen können und sagen können, so ey, davon kam irgendwie die Urheberrechtsverletzung, du darfst unsere Seite nicht mehr aufrufbar machen. Aber das heißt nicht mehr, dass sie ihren Grund und Boden quasi in Zahlungen, in Unterlassungserklärungen erbringen.
Ist das Problem jetzt endgültig vom Tisch und wie haben sich da die Parteien verhalten?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie sie sich verhalten haben. Es gab einfach massiven Druck, auch von Seiten der Zivilgesellschaft. Ich muss sagen, die digitale Gesellschaft hat da eine ganz gute Arbeit gemacht und immer wieder Stellungnahmen hingeschickt. Und eigentlich musste man irgendwann einsehen, es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund, diese Störerhaftung weiter aufrechtzuerhalten. Also es gab irgendwie kein vernünftiges Argument dafür, irgendwie Leuten zu sagen, wenn ihr euer WLAN aufmacht, dann kriegt ihr Abmahnungen ins Haus.
Sind die Content-Industrie das auch so?
Ich glaube nicht. Aber die Content-Industrie ist jetzt nicht so der wahnsinnige Sympathieträger. Also ich glaube, dieses Geschäftsmodell von Abmahnanwälten, dass sie ihr gesamtes Geld damit verdienen, indem sie irgendwelche Leute abmahnen, die sich mal von der falschen Seite was runterladen, ist, glaube ich, niemandem so richtig sympathisch. Das ist jetzt keine Industrie, die man fördern will.
Christian, wie ist es denn bei dir eigentlich? Was ist denn dein netzpolitischer Höhepunkt aus der letzten Legislaturperiode oder Tiefpunkt?
Genau, ich habe einen Tiefpunkt, einen Höhepunkt. Der Tiefpunkt ist genauso wie bei dir eigentlich die G10-Gesetzgebung und vor allem auch der Blick in andere Länder und die Erkenntnis, dass eigentlich Massenüberwachungstools legalisiert wurden überall. Meine Hoffnung bei der Sache ist, dass das einfach der Beginn des rechtsstaatlichen Auseinandersetzungen mit diesen Gesetzen ist, die dann mit breiter Koalition bekämpft werden. Ein bisschen Hoffnung gibt mir, dass in Deutschland es doch auch schon ziemlich viele Leute gibt, die sich dagegen ausgesprochen haben. Unter anderem der konservative ehemalige Präsident des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, Hans-Jürgen Papier, der da eigentlich ein ziemlich kritisches Gutachten auch dazu geschrieben hat. Aber dass das auf der ganzen Welt eigentlich eine ähnliche Bewegung gab, diese Tools sozusagen zu legalisieren, das hat mich einfach erschüttert, muss ich sagen. Und der Höhepunkt ist im gleichen Kontext für mich ganz klar die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung. Also das europäische Datenschutzgesetz, das natürlich kritisch und diskutiert wurde, aber auch willkommen geheißen wurde. Was auf jeden Fall ein Unterschied ist, ist, dass der Datenschutz jetzt ein viel, viel schärferes Schwert hat und man spürt es richtig sozusagen.
Tatsächlich?
Ja.
Ja, also der Markt für Datenschutzbeauftragte ist halt momentan so ein bisschen leer, weil ganz viele große Unternehmen grad merken so, huch, hier ist ja so ein Aufgabenkatalog, den muss ich demnächst mal erfüllen. Und wenn nicht, dann riskier ich auch dann was.
Aber das ist genau die Frage, weil du sagst grad schärferes Schwert. Ich hab ja den, ja, ich hab bis jetzt immer so, also Datenschützer können eigentlich, da gibt es nichts, was sie so richtig machen können, außer vielleicht mal so ein bisschen Bußgeld verhängen. Was ist denn das scharfe Schwert, was sie jetzt bekommen haben?
Bußgeld in Höhe von vier Prozent des Unternehmensumsatz, Jahresumsatzes oder maximal in Höhe von, also alternativ von 25 Millionen Euro. Und vor allem diese vier Prozent des Unternehmensumsatzes für einzelne Datenschutzverstöße ist was, was sozusagen Datenschutzprobleme sofort in, bei einem großen Unternehmen sofort in den Vorstand bringt. Also das müssen dann die obersten, obersten in so einem Unternehmen entscheiden. Und dementsprechend wird das auch viel, viel wichtiger. Auf der anderen Seite das Marktortprinzip, das heißt, wer in Europa mit Daten tätig ist, muss sich an die Datenschutzregeln hier halten. Das heißt, Datenschutzbeauftragte werden nicht nur in Europa gesucht, sondern auch im, überall in der Welt, im Silicon Valley. Und wir haben eben auch, wir merken das bei Gastwissenschaftlern, es gibt ein ganz, ganz großes Interesse. Und gleichzeitig, zum Beispiel in Brasilien, ist das europäische Datenschutzrecht jetzt auch zum Vorbild geworden. Also, das gibt mir eine verhaltene Hoffnung, dass das doch viel wichtiger wird, als es früher war.
Das Deprimierende ist halt sozusagen, das Positivste, was man rausziehen kann, ist eine verhaltene Hoffnung.
Ja, wobei eigentlich, also ich würde das jetzt nicht der großen Koalition anrechnen, weil die kann da gar nicht so viel für, beziehungsweise die hat einiges dafür getan, dass es ein bisschen schlimmer wird.
Sondern wem haben wir das dann zu verdanken?
Na, das haben wir im Endeffekt der EU als solche zu verdanken. Also da waren ja noch mehr Leute daran beteiligt, außer deutschen Vertretern. Und außerdem hat dann die Bundesregierung dadurch, dass sie ja Teile dessen nochmal in deutschem Recht regeln musste, mit einem neuen Datenschutzgesetz, sag ich mal, diverse Sachen eingebaut, die das Ganze nochmal abschwächen. Also zum Beispiel hat sie dann in diesem Gesetz nochmal untergebracht, dass die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte von sich aus das Parlament nicht über Missstände bei Nachrichtendiensten informieren soll. Auch wenn das eigentlich nicht so viel damit zu tun gehabt hätte, aber sie haben das zumindest noch mal genutzt, um da noch ein paar Sachen rein zu drücken. Deshalb ja, dieses europäische Ding ist schön, aber das, was die Bundesregierung daraus gemacht hat, finde ich eher nicht so schön.
Ja, oder was auch noch, sag ich mal, ehrlich gesagt verstörend ist in Anbetracht diverser Entwicklungen im Bereich Gesundheitswesen, ist auch, dass, sag ich mal, präventive Datenschutzkontrollen bei Berufsgeheimnisträgern beim Umsetzungsgesetz jetzt in Deutschland eingeschränkt wurden. Das heißt, Datenschutzbeauftragte dürfen nicht mehr unangemeldet, sag ich mal, beispielsweise Ärzte kontrollieren. Und das sind zum Teil sensibler Daten. Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich hab mal auf dem Sperrmüll in so Krankenakten eines Frauenarztes gehöhlt. Und wenn man sich überlegt, das sind Daten, die nicht nur, sag ich mal, die Patienten selbst betreffen, sondern im Zweifel bei Erbkrankheiten eben auch die Kinder und Kindeskinder. Und ja, das ist, sag ich mal, so ein Beispiel, ähnlich wie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo im Wustfortsatz noch andere Sachen dran gehängt wurden, die jetzt, sag ich mal, nicht im Kernbereich was damit zu tun haben, wurde, sag ich mal, unter dem Hurra-Jubel, dass die EU-Datenschutz-Grundverordnung jetzt kommt, von der Bundesregierung klammheimlich so eine Verschlimmbesserung eingeführt. Und da muss man eben aufpassen.
Ich bin jetzt kurz verwirrt. Bei der Vorratsanspeicherung war es ja immer so, dass eines der Argumente war, Moment mal, da sind ja auch die ganzen Berufsgeheimnisträger mit betroffen. Also Anwälte, Ärzte, Journalisten, deren Daten werden da auch gespeichert. Und das geht ja nicht, weil die ja von Beruf Geheimnisträger sind. Jetzt wird aber gesagt, also eigentlich wäre es eine gute Idee, wenn man Unangemeldet zu Berufsgeheimnisträgern kommt und mal deren Datenhaltung durchguckt. Wie passt das zusammen?
Naja, also mal so ein ganz konkretes Beispiel. Ich habe ja auch mal beispielsweise ein Praktikum beim unabhängigen Landesdatenschutzzentrum in Schleswig-Holstein gemacht, wo auch der Tilo Weichert damals Landesdatenschutzbeauftragter war. Und diesen teilweise eben auch, wenn Beschwerden kamen, dass beispielsweise in Arztpraxen eben Datenschutzverstöße da sind, eben auch mal hingegangen, um zu kontrollieren, um zu gucken, was denn da ist.
Aber gucken die sich dann die Daten an? Also die von der wir gerade sagten...
Naja, also einzelne Sachen, wie beispielsweise, ob irgendwo eine Videokamera in einem Umkleideraum hängt. Das ist halt so, siehst du halt relativ offensichtlich. Du kannst halt, sag ich mal schon, die einzelnen Sachen anschauen. Und zumindest, also man muss sich ja auch mal überlegen, in dem Bereich, wo klar ist, also wenn, sag ich mal, das Memen des rechtsfreien Raumes ist ja immer so sehr beliebt. Und wenn ich halt weiß, dass ich in keinem Fall mit einer Kontrolle zu rechnen kann, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das, sag ich mal, so den Datenschutzstandard unbedingt erhöht. Ich finde das absolut notwendig, dass die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte beispielsweise bei…
Aber nochmal, wie finden diese Kontrollen statt? Das kann mir nicht vorkommen. Wie kontrolliere ich sozusagen eine Datenbank darauf oder sozusagen die Computer eines Artes darauf, ohne mir die Daten anzugucken, von der ich eben genau nicht will, dass jemand anguckt, den ich nicht angehe, zum Beispiel mich als Datenschutzbeauftragter?
Aber das ist ja eigentlich ganz primitiv. Du kannst dir ja erst mal angucken, gibt es überhaupt ein Passwort für den Computer? Das heißt, steht der Computer einfach da rum und kann da jeder ran? Oder sind die Patientenakten in einem Schrank, den man abschließen kann? Das heißt, so Datenschutz gehört ja nicht nur die Datenbank. Da sind ja auch physische Sachen. Also kommt danach, keine Ahnung, kommt danach Praxis Schluss einfach jeder ran? Oder gibt es da eine Vorkehrung?
Also es geht sozusagen nicht darum, sich die Daten anzugucken, sondern die Struktur, in der die Daten liegen?
Und dann eben die Absicherung der Daten vor allem.
Kann man hier bei diesem Gesetz irgendwie noch Parteilinien ziehen? Also wir reden jetzt schon fast eineinhalb Stunden und ich hab so eine andere... Bei anderen Themen gibt es relativ krasse sozusagen, oder naja nicht krasse, aber sozusagen zumindest erkennbare Linien, sagen wir so. Und hier ist es eigentlich eher so, man muss eigentlich ja immer mit allen arbeiten. Man kann, also wir kommen ja nachher nochmal genau auf den Wahlkompass, aber dass du sagen, zumindest in den letzten 4 Jahren gar nicht so eine klare Parteilinien gab. Oder täuscht das jetzt?
Na das gab ja auch nur eine übergroße Koalition. Also wenn man sich so ein bisschen klarmacht, dass eine Opposition aus Grünen und Linken nicht mal ein Viertel der Stimmung ausmacht und das dann eine SPD mit einer CDU zusammen regiert, dann hat man irgendwann keinen Unterschied mehr. Ich meine, das ist ja der typische GroKo-Effekt, der da reintritt.
Na also ja, aber es ist zum Beispiel so, also Ehe für alle. Ehe für alle hat die SPD ja immer gesagt, also im Prinzip sind wir dafür, aber wir können gar nicht. Und das hat bei den Digitalteam, habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass sie sich sozusagen nicht mal im Anschein sozusagen unterscheiden.
Na ich glaube, die SPD ist bei vielen gezwungen, mit der CDU mitzuziehen.
Nein, aber das meinte ich ja gerade. Das hat sie bei der Ehe für alle ja auch gemacht, aber trotzdem immer noch mal zwischendurch gesagt, also eigentlich finden wir es schon eine gute Idee, aber halt jetzt Koalitionsvertrag.
Na es gab halt zwischendurch so ein paar Einzelne der SPD mit gewissen, die dann halt gesagt haben, finden wir kacke.
Ja, es gab tatsächlich, es gibt so einzelne Ortsverbände von der SPD. Ich glaube, Eimsbüttel war das in Hamburg, die so sehr nachhaltig sich gegen die Vorratsdatensprechung engagiert haben, oder eben einzelne Abgeordnete. Oder beispielsweise bei den Jusos gibt es eine ganz klare Ablehnung der Vorratsdatensprechung. Man muss aber auch sehen, dass einige, sage ich mal, Jusos auf den vorderen Plätzen, die dann auch ans Mikro gegangen sind und gesagt haben, Sigmar Gabriel so nicht, wir wollen das nicht. Und wir sind dagegen. Die wurden dann auch abgestraft. Die sind nicht auf den vorderen Plätzen gelandet bei den Listenaufstellungen für die Bundestagswahl. Und das ist natürlich so ein, finde ich ganz schlimmer, disziplinierender Effekt innerhalb großer Parteien, deren halt auch die zulasten der Vielfalt geht. Und mein Feedback auch von vielen Jusos, mit denen ich über das Thema gesprochen hab, war, dass es auch schwierig ist, bei einem so hohen Altersdurchschnitt wie bei der SPD, da wirklich viele Menschen für das Thema zu sensibilisieren und zu mobilisieren. Und das ist, denke ich mal, bei, also, beispielsweise die Grünen haben ja einen geringeren Altersdurchschnitt. Die FDP auch. Die Linke ist, glaube ich, ungefähr genauso alt wie die SPD. Ja, das kommt erschwerend hinzu.
Ja, aber ich teile deinen Eindruck, also ich glaube, bei diesen großen Themen oder die großen Buzzwords schreiben sich eigentlich alle ins Programm. Der Teufel steckt dann im Detail. Nicht alle sind für Datenschutz, Innovation, IT-Sicherheit, aber was das bedeutet, sozusagen auf konkrete Fragen, ich glaube, da liegen dann Unterschiede und wie gesagt, auch innerhalb von Parteien nicht.
Wir sind jetzt, also das, also ja, okay, sag ich jetzt einfach so. Wir sprechen gleich in der letzten Halbzeit von Hobby Zukunft. Ich möchte jetzt, bevor wir zu den Nachrichten kommen, noch zwei kleine Details klären. Das eine ist, wir haben gleich noch eine Hörerfrage. Robin hat angerufen. Und das andere ist, in der Vorbereitungsliste, die ihr mitgegeben habt, steht auch etwas drin, wo ich so denke, was macht das hier? Das erste Gesetz zur Änderung des Gesetzes über den deutschen Wetterdienst. Was hat das mit Digitalthemen zu tun? Oder hat euch das jemand reingeschmuggelt und ihr wisst es auch nicht?
Ich kenne es nicht im Detail, aber es geht auf jeden Fall darum, wie der deutsche Wetterdienst seine Daten zur Verfügung stellen darf. Das war irgendwie auf jeden Fall was gut. Ich glaube, er darf jetzt mehr als vorher oder zumindest wurde es nochmal geregelt.
Okay, das ist das Überthema Open Data.
Genau.
Also es gibt ja diese Forderung, die Regierung kriegt ja von uns Geld durch die Steuern. Da werden ganz viele Daten produziert. Und die wollen wir eigentlich alle immer sehen. Und das zu sagen, der deutsche Wetterdienst ist da eine dieser Sachen. Gibt es da eigentlich? Also ich bin ja hier auf der Suche immer nach Parteilinien. Gibt es da sozusagen, was diese Open Data Nummer angeht, Dinge, wo man sagen kann, okay, da gibt es so konservative und liberale Ansichten?
Ich glaube, dass grundsätzlich mittlerweile die meisten für Open Data sind, aber aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Die einen betonen eher sozusagen eine Wirtschaftsförderung und den anderen geht es vor allem um Transparenz, Partizipation und die Möglichkeit der Kontrolle.
Aber es bildet sich so ein gesellschaftlicher Konsens ab, der auch in der Politik sich widerspiegelt? Letztlich ist es uns ja egal, warum, Hauptsache sie machen es.
Ich denke schon. Es gibt jetzt eben das Open Data Gesetz, das das E-Government-Gesetz auch für die Bundesministerien geändert hat. Die müssen jetzt auch mit gewissen Ausnahmen, aber in der Regel eben ihre Daten veröffentlichen. Und Deutschland ist auch international im Rahmen der Open Government Initiative tätig geworden, ist in einen Dialog mit der Zivilgesellschaft eingetreten. Und der gerade sozusagen mit der Lobbyarbeit bei Gesetzesinitiativen, da wurde auch auf Netzpolitik berichtet, ist über Informationsfreiheit sozusagen, über den Umweg von ganz vielen Informationsfreiheitsanfragen auch erreicht worden, dass alle Lobbyeingaben für die ganze Legislaturperiode veröffentlicht werden, zu jedem Gesetz. Das dauert jetzt eine ganze Weile, aber das scheint mir doch auch ein großer Fortschritt zu sein, dass alles transparent gemacht wird jetzt.
Das finde ich eigentlich auch eine erfreuliche Entwicklung, dass ich dafür, ja, konzentriert abzeichnet. Wer hätte das gedacht? So, jetzt haben wir noch Robin, 25 Jahre, aus Frankfurt, der eine Frage hat, die sich immer wieder stellt, wenn man über den Umgang mit geleakten Materialen spricht. Hallo Robin.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Bitte stell deine Frage.
Es geht mir noch mal kurz um ein Thema, was vorhin kurz angesprochen wurde, um die Datenhehlerei. Da hatte ich jetzt einfach nur mal so die Frage, weil da ging es darum, dass im Gespräch war, die Daten, die Whistleblower zur Verfügung stellen, und Journalisten dafür hafbar zu machen, wenn sie eventuell irgendwas damit anstellen. Und jetzt wollte ich einfach mal fragen, wie das denn eigentlich sein kann zum Beispiel, dass man auf der einen Seite so was strafbar machen will, und auf der anderen Seite aber zum Beispiel die deutschen Steuerbehörden, CDs einkaufen von ausländischen Banken zum Beispiel, um Steuerhinterzieher zu überführen. Weil das ist ja auch nicht legal. Das sind ja auch eigentlich beschaffte Daten, mit denen man so ohne Weiteres eigentlich nicht arbeiten dürfen sollte. Oder ja, wenn man jetzt mit dieser Datenhehlerei so aufgreift.
Kann man annehmen?
Ich hör Gerichte da im Hintergrund.
Oder ist das sozusagen, ist das etwas, wo ich ja auch sag Ja, stimmt, das wüssten wir auch gerne.
Ja, also das war auf jeden Fall auch so ein What-the-fuck-Moment. Also das sieht man aber leider häufiger, dass mit zweierlei Maß gemessen wird. Aber, ja.
Wir müssen leider an dieser Stelle passen. Wir wissen's auch nicht.
Kein Problem.
Dann viel Spaß noch.
Danke, euch auch.
So, ja, das ist ja auch schön. Dinge, die nicht geklärt sind. Gut, wir werden uns gleich mal mit der Zukunft beschäftigen. Können vielleicht klären, welche Parteien, was uns in Zukunft versprechen. Vorher gibt es noch eine kleine Musik vom Sommer 2017 Semmler von Z-Tapes, nämlich Picking Up Trash von Euphoria.
Die Londoner Polizei prüft nach dem Hochhausbrand im Grenfell Tower ein Verfahren gegen die Behörden wegen fahrlässiger Tötung. In einem Schreiben der Polizei heißt es, es gebe hinreichende Verdachtsmomente, um ein solches Verfahren einzuleiten. Die Polizei will Beamte der Stadtverwaltung und der für den sozialen Wohnungsbau zuständigen Organisation befragen. Bei dem Brand Mitte Juni waren mindestens 80 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Das Feuer hatte sich schnell ausgebreitet, weil die Fassadenverkleidung leicht entzündlich war. Das Gewitter über Berlin hat am Abend zu Verzögerungen im Flugbetrieb geführt. Das haben die Flughafenbetreiber auf Twitter mitgeteilt. Ankommende Flüge hatten in Schönefeld teilweise mehr als 45 Minuten Verspätung. Auch in Tegel gab es Verspätungen. Manche Passagiere kamen erst rund eine Stunde später an. Nach dem tödlichen Angriff auf jüdische Siedler im Westjordanland hat Israels Ministerpräsident Netanyahu die Todesstrafe für den Attentäter gefordert. Der Regierungschef sagte, die Zeit für die Todesstrafe sei in extremen Fällen gekommen. Ein 19-jähriger Palästinenser hatte am vergangenen Freitag drei Israelis in einer jüdischen Siedlung getötet. Das israelische Recht lässt die Todesstrafe zwar zu, seit der Gründung des Staates wurde sie aber nur einmal angewendet. In der Nähe von Frankfurt Oder hat das Helene Beach Festival begonnen. Der tagelange Regen in Brandenburg hatte die Anreise etlicher Besucher verzögert und den Aufbau erschwert, wie die Organisatoren mitteilten. Straßen und Wege mussten verdichtet und Wasser abgebumpt werden. Das Musikfestival dauert bis zum Sonntag. Rund 120 Künstler sollen auf sieben Bühnen auftreten. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Zehlendorf und Adlershof 16 Grad, Ludwigshalde 15 Grad, Cottbus, Neuropin und Lindenberg melden aktuell 18 Grad. Am Abend und in der Nacht kann es vor allem im Süden noch schauern und gewittern, sonst bleibt es trocken. Der Freitag bringt Wolken und ein paar Schauer. Im Laufe des Tages lässt sich auch mal die Sonne blicken. Das Ganze bei Höchstwerten von 23 Grad in Berlin und 24 Grad in Brandenburg. Vorsicht auf der A10, nördlicher Berliner Ringen, Richtung Dreieck-Bahnim. Zwischen Dreieck-Pankow und Dreieck-Bahnim sind Radfahrer unterwegs. Vorsicht auf der A13, Berlin Richtung Dresden. Zwischen Barothmarck und Starkow steht ein defekter Lkw auf der Standspur. A24, Berlin Richtung Hamburg, zwischen Dreieck-Wittschok, Dosse und Raststätte, Stolpe Nord, ist ein Schwertransport unterwegs, den nicht überholt werden kann. Vorsicht auf der A115, Zubringer Nutetal Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Saarmoot und Potsdam-Drewitz steht ein defektes Fahrzeug auf der Standspur. Und Vorsicht im Kreis Uckermark auf der L284, zwischen Flimsdorf und Felcho befindet sich ein Rehbock auf der Fahrbahn. Allen unterwegs und da, wo es geht, nur gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz im Live- oder Musikstream hören wollt, dann geht doch mal auf fritz.de slash Streambox.
Im Chaos Radio in Blue Moon gibt's jetzt die Nerd-News, geschrieben von Moe vom Chaos Computer Club und präsentiert von Merlin Schulz.
Flash ist tot. Das Browser Plug-in Flash wird bis 2020 schrittweise eingestellt. Das hat der Hersteller Adobe am Dienstag verkündet. Das Flash Plug-in macht in den letzten Jahren zumeist durch Negativschlagzeilen auf sich aufmerksam. Flash verbinden viele User vor allem mit kritischen Sicherheitslücken, hohem Energieverbrauch, langen Ladezeiten und Browser abstürzen. Firefox stirbt. Der Mozilla-Browser Firefox ist vom Aussterben bedroht. Sein Marktanteil auf dem Desktop ist auf rund 14 Prozent geschrumpft. Microsofts Internet Explorer liegt bei gut 9 Prozent. Von der schwächelnden Konkurrenz profitiert vor allem Google Chrome. Sein Anteil am Desktop-Markt beträgt mittlerweile 63 Prozent. Roomba spioniert. iRobot, der Hersteller der Staubsagerroboter Roomba, will Daten über die Wohnung der Nutzer verkaufen. In einem Interview mit der Nachrichtenagentur Reuters räumte iRobot-Chef Colin Engel ein, dass das große datenschutzrechtliche Fragen aufwerfe. Er versicherte aber, dass man sich die Einwilligung der Nutzer einholen werde. Die würden dem aber sowieso zustimmen, um ihr Smart-Home smarter zu machen.
Falls ihr die Hürden-News selber noch mal nachlesen und nachklicken wollt, auf chaosradio.ccc.de gibt es nach der Sendung die passenden Links. Präsentiert wurden sie von Merlin Schulz. Vielen Dank. Chaosradio im Blumen, eine halbe Stunde haben. Entschuldigung, mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich habe einen Froschumhals. Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch, um uns über die Wahlprogramme der Bundestagsparteien und deren digitale Ausprägung zu unterhalten. Warum machen wir das? Weil wir heute in der Sendung einen Rückblick gehalten haben auf die letzten vier Jahre digitale Politik, die Regierung und auch der Opposition. Und wir haben eine Sache vergessen, nämlich den Staatstrojaner. Haben wir einen Staatstrojaner? Wer hat uns einen Staatstrojaner gebracht und was kann er überhaupt?
Wir haben eigentlich schon ziemlich lange einen Staatstrojaner. Also eigentlich darf man so einen Staatstrojaner seit 2009 einsetzen, aber nur für, also nur gegen Terror.
Na, aber der war doch auch kaputt zwischendurch, oder?
Der war kaputt, der durfte mehr als er sollte, als er, nee, der konnte mehr als er durfte, so rum. Und eigentlich ist das auch immer noch so, zumindest den, den man sich eingekauft hat, den prüft man jetzt, glaube ich, in der dritten Version. Und irgendwie kann er immer noch mehr als er darf. Das heißt, eigentlich darf man ja nur so laufende Kommunikation damit abfangen. Das heißt, bevor sie verschlüsselt wird, aber halt schon so laufende Kommunikation. Aber leider können die Dinge halt immer auch noch so gucken, was man so auf seinem Telefon hat und alte Nachrichten lesen. Und das kriegt man denen einfach nicht ausgetrieben. Also prüft man, prüft man, prüft man. Dann hat irgendwann das BKA gesagt, machen wir halt selber einen. Und da soll jetzt auf jeden Fall dieses Jahr noch eine erweiterte Variante kommen, die eben nicht nur Skype mitschneiden kann, sondern auch Sachen von Messagerdiensten lesen kann. Und es wurde ausgeweitet, wie man den einsetzen darf. Den darf man jetzt auch bei so Spaßeinsätzen wie Schmuggel von Anabolika. Also nicht mehr nur bösem Terror, sondern auch alles Mögliche andere.
Warte mal, war es nicht auch bei der Vorarztatenspeicherung so, dass die Kritiker gesagt haben, dass werden sie bestimmt noch für andere Sachen benutzt, als die ganzen Schwerverbrechen, die es am Anfang eingeführt wurde. Und dann kam das auch so?
Sowas würde bei Sicherheitsgesetzen niemals passieren.
Niemals. Das würde auch beispielsweise bei der PKW-Maut nie gemacht werden, was beispielsweise in einem neuen Unionswahlprogramm dann plötzlich gesagt wird, hoch, wir können es auch für andere Dinge verwenden, würden die niemals tun.
Aber es gibt doch gar keine PKW-Maut, die würde doch auch niemals kommen.
Wir leben in einem Paralleluniversum, in dem wir aber bald wieder wählen müssen. Aber ich will vorhin noch fragen, Staatsverwanderer, gibt es denn da so Parteilinien? So gibt es da dafür und dagegen Leute?
Ich glaube, die SPD hat sich schon eine Weile, wer oder weniger, gesträubt und da gab es dann auch zwei SPD-Lamitgewissen, die viel zitierten, die dann gesagt haben, ne, das können wir so nicht durchgehen lassen.
Warte mal, wir haben den ganzen Abend jetzt darüber gesprochen, es gibt zwei SPD-Lamitgewissen. Nur mal für den größten Vergleich, weil ich es leider gerade nicht im Kopf habe, wie viel Sitze hat die SPD?
Wie auch das will, das müssen wir in diesem Internet nachgucken.
Okay, gut, mach das mal jemand anders.
Aber ich muss sagen, in der Zwischenzeit, diese Ausweitung des Einsatzes Staatsroyal, das war schon ziemlich stunt, weil es ist eine kreative Hochleistung, wie sie das geschafft haben. Sie haben das nämlich untergebracht in einem Gesetz über das Fahrverbot als Nebenstrafe. Was? Ja, über das Gesetz als Fahrverbot als Nebenstrafe, damit man zum Beispiel Jugendliche abschrecken kann, irgendwelche bösen Dinge zu tun, indem man sagt, dann nehmen wir deinen Führerschein weg. Sachen, die gar nichts mit dem Fahren zu tun haben. Und dann war dieses Gesetz irgendwie schon so ein bisschen fertig und dann hat der Bundestag noch mal eine Formulierungshilfe von der Bundesregierung bekommen, was sie denn da noch so reinmachen könnte. Und das war dann plötzlich der Staatstrojaner. Unglaublich witzig, weil selbst die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte wusste das nicht, die hat das dann bei uns gelesen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein ziemlich geiler Stunt, wenn man irgendwas unterbringen will, auf jeden Fall in einem Gesetz unterbringen, das überhaupt nicht so klingt, als könnte man es da unterbringen, zum Beispiel das Fahrverbot als Nebenstrafe.
Das ist ja ganz großartig. Und da hat die SPD zugestimmt. Ach ja, es gab ja zwei. Ach übrigens, wollt ihr mal raten?
199.
So, also die SPD, eine Volkspartei, hat zwei mit damit gewissen. Und naja, gut, schön. Kommen wir jetzt, bevor die Sendung vorbei ist, zu dem Wahlprogramm und dem Wahlkompass digital. Es entstanden am Humboldt Institut für Intelligenz und Gesellschaft. Und wir haben schon geklärt, ihr habt euch die Parteien angeguckt, die laut der Umfrage 2016 mal über fünf Prozent gekommen wären. Ist also auch die AfD dabei, ist auch die FDP dabei und die, die jetzt im Bundestag sind. Was für Themen habt ihr euch denn angeschaut?
Wir haben versucht, eben alle möglichen Digitalthemen zu identifizieren, also in allen Bereichen Arbeit, Wirtschaft, Soziales, Sicherheit, Datenschutz. Es muss eben einen Digitalbezug haben. Das war für uns besonders wichtig, weil wir gemerkt haben, dass Digitalpolitik mittlerweile sozusagen in allen Bereichen eine Rolle spielt. Und wir wollten einfach einen Überblick geben über die verschiedenen Themen, sodass wir das gelabelt haben. Und wer sich für ein bestimmtes Thema interessiert, kann dieses Label klicken und dann sehen, wo das überall auftaucht in verschiedenen Programmen. Und er kann diese Programme auch vergleichen.
Jetzt haben wir schon im Rückblick festgestellt, also so richtig doll viele Unterschiede zwischen den Parteien gibt es meistens nicht, wenn es Digitalen gibt. Wie ist das denn jetzt im Wahlkampf? Da will man sich ja möglichst absetzen von den anderen und sagen, hier wir sind die Allerschufsten. Wird das im Digitalbereich auch gemacht oder ist das noch so, wir sind zwar im Neuland drin, aber das Digitale ist eher so hinten dran?
Ich glaube, dass es es gibt unterschiedliche Akzente. Alle Parteien haben das haben das doch schon sehr stark verankert. Allerdings würde ich sagen, in der unterschiedlichen Tiefe und manchmal, also gerade wenn es an institutionelle Fragen geht, dann gibt es doch deutliche Unterschiede. Wie das Digitale überhaupt verankert werden soll in der Regierung, wo die FDP zum Beispiel ein Digitalministerium fordert, dem haben sich jetzt alle kleinen Parteien in Teilen jedenfalls angeschlossen, oder ob es Digitalrat geben soll, wie das die CDU vorschlägt. Ganz interessant auch die Diskussion, die auch schon länger läuft, wie die Rolle des BSI aussehen soll. Also ob das immer noch das Bundesamt für die Sicherheit der Informationstechnik, ob das immer noch sozusagen eine nachgeordnete Behörde des Bundesinnenministeriums bleiben soll oder eben unabhängiger Garant für IT-Sicherheit.
Und das wäre, also um das sozusagen aufzuzeigen, warum das ein Unterschied ist, das Bundesinnenministerium sind ja auch die, die im Zweifel zu sagen, Staatsrojanereinsatz und sowas machen. Und das BSI ist ja theoretisch die Institution, die dafür sorgen soll, dass unsere Systeme so sicher sind, dass nicht mal ein Staatsrojaner reinkommt. Kleiner Interessenkonflikt also.
Ganz genau. In München, das wäre auch eine Entwicklung, die man noch erwähnen könnte, ist ja CITES gegründet worden, auch im Rahmen des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes. Also eine Behörde, die Sicherheitslücken suchen soll, um die einzusetzen in der Strafverfolgung.
Wer hat uns denn das eigentlich eingebrockt? Die große Koalition, ohne Zweifel?
Ja, ohne Beteiligung des Parlaments. Also ganz geil, weil sie gesagt haben, wir brauchen... Ja, das ist total gut. Das kann man auch alles machen, ohne das Parlament zu fragen. Da hat man nämlich gar keine Abgeordneten Missgewissen mehr, weil man die einfach nicht mehr fragen muss. Da kann man nämlich einfach sagen, wir haben jetzt diese Cybersicherheitsstrategie und da gehen wir her und sagen, wir brauchen diese Behörde, um unsere Anstrengungen zu bündeln. Wir brauchen aber keine neue gesetzliche Grundlage, weil keine Behörde bekommt mehr Befugnis und das bleibt alles wie es ist. Wir machen das nur sinnvoller und effizienter. Wow.
Schön. Gibt es eigentlich, wenn man sich die Wahlprogramme anguckt, so eine Art Nordpartei? Also so Grundsätze sind ja irgendwie private Daten schützen, also die Gynallimine darf keiner rein, öffentliche Daten nützen, also irgendwie Transparenz etc. Überwachung abschaffen. So was gibt es sowas überhaupt? Kann man sowas wählen? Wenn ihr auf Chaos, auf wie heißt die URL? Streaming.ccc, nee, Media.streaming.ccc.de, wenn ihr da guckt, habt ihr gerade gesehen, wie sie so leicht fassungslos slash entgeisterte Blicke durchs Studio schweiften in der Hoffnung, dass es vielleicht so eine Partei geben könnte.
Es ist ein bisschen peinlich, das zu sagen. Aber wenn man sich das mal so anguckt, die Partei, die meiner Meinung nach ihre Forderungen am besten begründet, nicht die, mit der ich übereinschöme, ist die FDP. Zumindest in dem ganzen Digitalbereich, weil sie nicht nur sagen, wir wollen irgendwie so angemessene Informationsaustausch oder so ein Bullshit, sondern sie sagen, was du gerade gemacht hast. Sie sagen, was sie wollen und sie sagen, warum sie es wollen. Und sie sagen auch so nette Sachen, wir finden, es ist Quatsch, alle Bürger zu überwachen, weil wir uns das eh nicht leisten können. Deshalb sollten wir uns darum kümmern, nur die Einzelnen zu überwachen, die wir wirklich überwachen wollen.
Vor allem, man muss aber da wieder sagen, bei der FDP muss man wirklich diese Linie ziehen zwischen der Staat und die Bürger und Unternehmen und Bürger. Und sag ich mal, wenn es um Datenschutz im Bezug auf die Wirtschaft geht, habe ich da gar nicht so den starken Eindruck von Seiten der FDP. Da geht es eher wieder in den Bereich, wir wollen uns ja in Deutschland die Wirtschaft nicht kaputt machen und wir wollen ein bisschen mutig sein. Und es gibt da ein sehr interessantes Gespräch zwischen Christian Lindner und Frank Schirmacher. Ich glaube, das wurde mit gutem Willen angestoßen. Und man sieht, wie Herr Schirmacher dann immer weiter im Sitz versinkt und immer mehr so die Hand ins Gesicht rückt und einfach merkt, also Herr Lindner versteht nicht, worüber er spricht. Und das muss man eben da auch immer im Hinterkopf behalten. Mein Problem ist tatsächlich, jede Partei hat ihre Macken so. Es gibt einen Grund, warum ich damals in die Piraten eingetreten bin und nicht in eine Partei, die es einfach schon gibt. Und man muss auch sehen, dass die Parteien, wo man noch sagt, das ist am ehesten die reine Lehre im Wahlprogramm, da wird man aber auch teilweise so einen Realitätsabgleich machen müssen und sagen, wie realistisch ist es denn, dass man einen Kompromiss aushandelt, falls man denn Teil eines Regierungsbündnisses ist? Und sind Bürgerrechte wirklich der Bereich, wo wir uns in die Bresche schlagen? Und natürlich gibt es in allen Parteien Supernetzpolitiker, die sich dafür einsetzen, aber ob die sich insgesamt durchsetzen können, da habe ich überall meine Zweifel. Und das ist so mein großes Problem, was ich habe. Und ich kann jetzt tatsächlich noch nicht sagen, wie ich wählen werde. Und ich glaube, da geht es ganz vielen nur als genauso wie mir.
Ja, aber es ist auch ein bisschen fatal, seine Wahlentscheidung von netzpolitischen Themen abhängig zu machen.
Das ist gerade meine nächste Frage gewesen. Also wie hoch würdet ihr, jetzt kommen wir sozusagen nicht mehr objektiv, in Anführungszeichen, klar, aber wie hoch würdet ihr das persönlich sozusagen hängen? Also wie wichtig ist euch dieser digitale Block in einem kompletten Wahlprogramm? Wie hoch priorisiert ihr das? Oder kann man oder ich würde fast denken, man kann das eigentlich nicht mehr trennen. Also sagen, ich habe gerade sozusagen so eine Extremfrage. So viele theoretische Diskussionen wäre jetzt gewesen, okay, wir stellen uns mal vor, es gibt eine Partei, die macht alles exakt so wie ihr das wollt, nur im digitalen schlägt sie völlig in die Gegenrichtung. Würdet ihr so was wählen? Und dann dachte ich so, das kann man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so trennen, weil es so stark im Leben ist, das geht gar nicht mehr.
Ja, außerdem Job Security, man muss ja auch die nächsten vier Jahre nur was zu tun haben.
Ah, du möchtest also die Überwachungspartei wählen, damit Netzpolitik Org noch verstehe. Du sagst mir jetzt am Ende der Sendung, bekomme ich jetzt mit, dass ich eine große Verschwörung aufgesessen bin. Arbeitsbeschaffung für... Oh mein Gott. Aber weil Carla es jetzt schon gesagt hat, wisst ihr schon, was ihr wählt? Oder habt ihr eine Idee? Und das ist wie eine wie große Rolle hat der netzpolitische Teil gespielt? Christian?
Also ich hab eine Idee und eigentlich, wie du gesagt hast, das Netzpolitische hat eine große Rolle gespielt, aber im Kontext eben. Weil ich glaube, in vielen Bereichen Zukunft der Arbeit und auch das ist für mich auch ein interessanter Trend bei den Programmen. Digitalisierung heißt jetzt nicht mehr nur Internet, sondern ganz viel sozusagen auch Automatisierung in verschiedenen Bereichen. Und das scheint mir doch so wichtiges Thema zu sein, dass mich das schon wesentlich geprägt hat. Zusammen mit Privacy-Fragen, wo ich wirklich auch sozusagen allein in der Art und Weise, wie Parteien das verteidigen, einen Unterschied sehe. Und das ist für mich auf jeden Fall auch ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt.
Kannst du noch kurz umreißen, wie die einzelnen Parteien da stehen?
Wir haben es hier bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Also ich denke, es ist immer gut, das sozusagen an Beispielen zu klären. Und bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wir es ja eigentlich schon diskutiert, nicht? Also jeder hat das irgendwo im Wahlprogramm. Aber an der Stelle mache ich sozusagen auch ein bisschen Werbung für unseren Wahlkompass Digitalis. Man kann eben auch ins Detail schauen. Man kann dann die Forderungen genau vergleichen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig, um eben, wie gesagt, auch die Kräfte in den Parteien zu stützen, die das auch unterstützen und die Abgeordneten auch daran zu erinnern. Nicht später dann. Denn ich glaube, es gibt auch in der Digitalpolitik und ich würde denken, auch unter Nerd sozusagen unterschiedliche Themen, die unterschiedlich wichtig sind.
Ich würde ja gerne sagen, jetzt noch ein populistisches Thema. So ein Fragen, wie da der Stand ist. Und das ist ich habe gerade überlegt, so womit das Ding ist, ist ja immer so eine negative Überwachung und Staatsruh. Das ist alles so fürchterlich. Und was könnte man denn noch im Wahlpokal schreiben, wo man sozusagen sagt, ja, das finden wir auf jeden Fall geil. Und das ist ja eigentlich Breitbandausbau. Also ich würde denken sozusagen, jede Partei verspricht uns jetzt mindestens Glasfaser bis an den Nachtisch.
Bis 2025.
Nein, bis nächstes Jahr natürlich.
Nee, bis 2025 steht da.
Im Wahlprogramm.
Ja, ich glaube, welches war das? Also Glasfaserausbau, wir sind quasi schon da.
Gut, also CDU bis 2025 gibt es, wer bietet mehr? Habt ihr da mal geguckt?
Niemand.
Was? Also niemand will hat einen konkreten, ich glaube, ich bin wirklich, ich glaube, es war die CDU. Niemand will so ein konkretes Ziel erreichen, hält und niemand erhält den Anspruch, kompletten Glasfaserausbau jeder Haushalt bis an die Haustür in einer bestimmten Zeitspanne zu haben.
Gibt es irgendwelche anderen Ideen, wie man breitbandiges Internet? Also ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein Thema, da könnte man ja total viel versprechen. Wir machen LTE flächendeckend für alle oder weiß der Geier was?
Vor allem ist es lustig.
Internet in Luftballons.
Ja, wenn man sich überlegt, alle versprechen einem Glasfaser, also durch die Bank weg.
Ja, das schon.
Und wenn man sich dann anguckt, was in den letzten Jahren passiert ist, wenn man sich denkt, wir machen jetzt so eine künstliche, lebensverlängernde Maßnahme für unsere Kopferleitung und momentan sieht es überhaupt nicht nach Glasfaserausbau aus, weil es halt irgendwie zu teuer ist, dann denkt man sich schon so, was ist bei euch eigentlich los? Also was denkt ihr denn, was dann nächstes Jahr passiert und plötzlich haben dann alle Glasfaser? Und ganz witzig sind auch so die Finanzierungsideen, die Leute haben. Ich glaube, die FDP will die Aktien, also will die Staatsaktien an der Telekom und an der deutschen Post verkaufen. Ich glaube, die Grünen wollen die an der Telekom alleine verkaufen und irgendjemand anderes will Mobilfunklizenzen verkaufen und damit das Geld für den Glasfaserausbau kriegen. Aber ich sag mal, selbst wenn man das Geld auf einen Schlag hätte, würde ich es ein bisschen für unrealistisch halten, bis 2025 überall Glasfaser zu haben.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle das Chaosradio 233 empfehlen. Da haben wir schon mal ausführlich über den Glasfaserausbau gesprochen. Und ich dachte sozusagen, wie wenigstens jetzt zum Wahlkampf verteilt jemand sozusagen, keine Ahnung, dicke Glasfaserbündel mit seinem Parteiaufkleber drauf oder so was.
Das ist kein schlechter Idee.
Richterentwürft Wahlprogramme. Was ist denn noch, was ich auch noch eine interessante Frage finde, ist, wir haben ja die Sendung angefangen mit dem Neuland Zitat von Merkel, die ja sozusagen quasi so getan hat, habt ihr mir erklärt, dass sie das Internet noch gar nicht kennt, was Quatsch ist. Jetzt, wenn man so in die Zukunft guckt und sich die Wahlprogramme anguckt, was ist denn die Technologie der nächsten vier Jahre, die völlig, also sagen, von der die Parteien dann völlig überrascht sein werden, dass sie jetzt ansteht und oh mein Gott, da haben wir ja gar nichts zu irgendwie auf dem Zettel?
Ja, also man stelle sich allein mal die Vorratsdatenspeicherung vor, wenn wir, wenn das sogenannte Internet auf Finks kommt und alle möglichen Gegenstände in meiner Wohnung plötzlich eine Datenspur hinterlassen. Und ich glaube, ja, also sag ich mal dieses real existierende Entwicklungen von immer mehr vernetzten Geräten und die vollkommene Unbereitschaft zu antizipieren, was so ein Überwachungsgesetz in so einer Umgebung dann ausrichtet. Also das zeigt mir mal wieder, dass man nicht genug sowohl Gewissen als auch Digitalkompetenz im Bundestag hat.
Okay, Internet auf Finks ist also ein Thema, was zumindest nicht in der ganzen Konsequenz bedacht wird. Was sind so mit autonomen Autos? Spielt das schon eine Rolle? Hat irgendjemand sich dafür eingesetzt zu sagen, yes, autonome Autos bis 2020 auf der Straße oder das Gegenteil, irgendwie verbieten, weil deutscher fahrspaß?
Ja, das hat sogar der Bundesverkehrsminister ins Spiel gebracht. Und da ist natürlich, ich mein, Autostandort Deutschland, da schreiben sich eigentlich viele, also die CDU und die SPD auch auf die Fahnen, auch die dahinter liegende Technologie, KI, soll gefördert werden. Ob man da allerdings genau versteht, was das für Konsequenzen haben kann, da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Vor allem auch bei Kontrollmechanismen, die SPD und die Grünen schlagen einen Algorithmen TÜV vor, lassen aber offen, was sie damit genau meinen und wie das umgesetzt werden soll.
Ja, es stellt sich dann ja auch eine ganz einfache Haftungsfrage, wenn mein autonomes Auto beispielsweise die Oma, die gerade irgendwie über die Straße huscht, anfährt, wer haftet dann eigentlich ich, weil ich in dem Auto sitze, der Hersteller des Autos oder aber der Hersteller der Software. Das sind dann halt beispielsweise schließlich der Kreis mit Softwarehaftung. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass man sich damit wirklich auseinandergesetzt hat. Und wie läuft dann so eine Versicherung beispielsweise ab? Und wie setzen sich die Prämien zusammen? Also sind aus meiner Sicht dann viele, viele ungelöste Fragen. Aber die wurden nicht nur in Deutschland noch nicht beantwortet.
Aber wäre ja trotzdem schön, wenn wir mal Vorreiter sein könnten und nicht irgendwie wie beim Breitbandaufbau.
Ja, aber ich glaube Autos ist da in Deutschland das ganz falsche Thema. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie weit man hierzulande beim Thema E-Mobilität ist. Also ganz traurig.
Ich habe heute gerade so einen schönen Tweet gesehen, wo jemand die Meldung kommentiert hat, dass VW gesagt hat, also wir können schon so einen Elektromotor bauen, aber dann bräuchten wir Geld von der Regierung, wie es so ein Riesenkonzern nicht schaffen kann, was Tesla alleine geschafft hat. Na gut, also was ich jetzt ein bisschen unbefriedigend finde, ist, dass ich, also ich will nicht sagen, ich bin nicht schlauer als vor der Sendung, weil das stimmt nicht. Ich weiß jetzt mehr, aber ich weiß nicht besser, wen ich sozusagen wählen könnte, woran ich das festmache. Habt ihr noch einen abschließenden Tipp an die Wählerinnen und Wähler da draußen, wie sie, wenn sie sich für Digitales interessieren, vorgehen sollen zur nächsten Bundestagswahl, die im September ansteht?
Ja, also ich würde mir wirklich Menschen raten, sich nicht nur die Bundestagswahlprogramme anzuschauen, sondern beispielsweise mal beim Netzpolitik nachzuschauen, was die einzelnen Parteien in der Vergangenheit gemacht haben. Denn wie wir schon gesagt haben, für Datenschutz sind alle und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich muss mich mal hier auch noch mal outen. Für mich ist tatsächlich Datenschutz und Netzpolitik mit ein ausschlaggebendes Thema dafür, ob ich eine Partei wähle oder nicht. Weil ich denke, es gibt viele wichtige kurzfristige Entscheidungen, die zu treffen sind. Ich glaube aber tatsächlich, dass die Frage, was mit unseren Daten geschieht, was für Geschäftsmodelle wir als legitime erachten in der Gesellschaft und so weiter und so fort, ganz viel auch zu sozialer Spaltung beitragen werden. Beispielsweise, wenn meine Krankenversicherung nach Gesundheitsdaten mir einen angepassten Zahnputzwenigputzertarif anbieten kann oder vielleicht jemanden mit Erbkrankheit dann anders behandelt. Also es hat alles, sag ich mal, Querschnittsmomente in allen möglichen Bereichen. Und der digitale Wandel wird auch aus meiner Sicht im Stichwort Digitalisierung, auch bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, großes Thema, immer mehr andere Politikbereiche erfassen. Und da erwarte ich, dass Parteien, die sich darauf bewerben, für die nächsten paar Jahre in einem Parlament sitzen und für mich abstimmen zu dürfen, wo er in meinem Namen indirekt da auch vorweisen kann, dass sie sich zumindest damit auseinandergesetzt haben. Und das kann man auch einfordern. Im Zweifel ruft man einfach seinen örtlichen Abgeordneten kurz vor der Wahl an und sagt so, ja, also Peter, jetzt ist die Zeit der Wahrheit wieder angebrochen. Ich habe mich das letzte Mal vor fünf Jahren gemeldet. Ja, wie sieht es denn aus? Was hast du denn so gemacht? Und wie stehst du denn zu folgenden Themen? Und selbst wenn dann eine Partei gewinnen sollte, wo eine Koalition drankommt, die wir uns alle nicht wünschen, sind da zumindest ein paar Leute, die ein paar ernste Gespräche geführt haben und vielleicht mal drüber nachdenken, in Zukunft einen Gewissen zu haben.
Okay, die Arbeit müssen wir doch noch selber machen. Christian, noch ganz kurz, wir sind fast wieder zu lang. Letzte Worte.
Versuchen, sich einzubringen, in die Diskussion zu kommen über gesellschaftliche Gruppen oder eben sozusagen in Parteien. Und ich glaube, da kriegt man am besten mit, was man auch gut findet. Und man muss den Dialog suchen, denn am 24.09. geht ja die Arbeit erst los, nicht? Und da darf man sozusagen nicht den Stimmzettel abgeben und die Stimme damit, sondern dann beginnt das Gespräch und das wäre mein Punkt.
Irgendwie endet es immer wieder da. Du musst doch selber arbeiten, Anna?
Ich würde diese ganze Wahlgeschichte nicht so fetischisieren. Also weil einfach, es ist eine Wahl, es ist irgendwie das, was an Parteien dann im Parlament sitzt. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass ich nichts anderes machen kann. Das heißt, wenn man irgendwie sagt, das ist irgendwie alles nicht so gut, kann ich ja trotzdem noch in meinem eigenen Wirkungsbereich Dinge tun. Zum Beispiel, dass jetzt diese ganzen Lobbypapiere für Gesetze verabschiedet wurden, liegt daran, dass genug Leute nachgenervt haben, bis sie halt gesagt haben, okay, es lohnt sich nicht mehr, das alles einzeln zu beantworten, wir machen das jetzt proaktiv. Und da würde ich einfach sagen, nicht unbedingt immer nur nach den Parteien gucken, sondern einfach mal gucken, was man selber machen kann.
Na schön, das war das Chaosradio mit einem Rückblick und Ausblick auf die Bundestagswahl. Und wir, also zu dem standardmäßigen Aufruf, geht wählen. Kommt jetzt also noch ein zweiter und der heißt, geht nerven. Vielen Dank Katharina, Christian und Anna. Und mein Name ist Marcs Richter, ich habe noch einen letzten Satz, und der heißt, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.